justin trudeau has lifted the emergency
order invoked to end the trucker
protests why yo everybody was yelling at
them and i think they realized it was
really really bad they were going to be
losing a lot of support they'd lost a
lot of support when you even had
individuals coming on this show who are
more you know mainstream personalities
saying it's martial law i think trudeau
realized maybe you made a big mistake
but it shows you how effective the
freedom convoy protests are that it
forced their hand
pulled the mask off now the canadian
government is instructing banks to
unfreeze the accounts why because
people were rightfully freaking out at
the prospect of the government seizing
your ass effectively without a court
order so this is huge at the same time
dc is confirming national guard is being
deployed there's two different u.s
convoys the people's convoy and the
freedom convoy both departing from
around l.a i believe plus a whole bunch
of other weird little convoys everywhere
protest is going to get lit
we got one that's going to be heading to
d.c on the first for the state of the
union national guard will be deployed
security fences are being set up and
then we've got another that's going to
get into dc on the fifth we'll see which
one you know we'll see how big these get
the people's convoy already raised
nearly 400 000 so this should get very
very interesting then we got some news
on ukraine get this joe biden reissues
the sanctions that donald trump had
signed into place
why he removed them i have no idea i
think they're trying to appease putin
it's clearly not working so now they're
backtracking and that won't work either
so we're going to talk about all that
stuff plus much much more joining us
is uh we have two documentarians jorge
and sognik you guys want to introduce
yourselves yeah my name is rory ventura
field recorder uh field reporter for the
daily caller
i'm sognik and i'm a producer for the
daily caller and you guys have seen it
all i mean
uh i don't i don't know if you were were
you on the ground stock nick at the uh
the kenosha stuff or no i wasn't no but
you were right yeah man yeah we sent it
on and from the you know the rights in
2020 to you know the lockdowns on small
businesses to the mental health aspect
on teens even you know basically start
of 2021 was the border crisis so we
started seeing the human smelling human
trafficking and it just seems like right
now under this administration the news
just
never stops yeah that's crazy right what
are you guys working on now so me and
sonic actually we just released um last
week it's our new documentary it's
called hero to zero and basically what
means i wanted to do is we wanted to
give a voice to all the first responders
especially in southern california that
refuse to to comply with the mandates
and who have been fired or been placed
on unpaid leave the reason why me and
sonic wanted to produce this documentary
was because we took a look at the
corporate press and
we we saw how the corporate press as you
guys know the frontline workers like
right anyone who worked at grocery
stores or nurses or firefighters they
held them as heroes for the past two
years right i'm from i'm from los
angeles so my mayor eric garcetti told
us that every night at 6pm we had to
come out and bang pots and pans for
these frontline workers now fast forward
to the mandates now those same frontline
workers have been demonized by the media
they've been fired la times put out an
editorial saying we need to build back
better by firing all the anti-vaxxer
firefighters so we felt um that we
wanted to give a voice back to the
workers and we didn't we didn't like how
the corporate press was just treating
regular first responders american
citizens working class that were on the
front lines for us while we were all
quarantined um so we want to give them a
voice that's why we actually named the
documentary from hero because they were
held as heroes so now zero where these
people are literally not getting paid
they cannot pay their mortgages can't
put food on the table for taking their
stance and i'm very proud of that i
think that's that's pertinent especially
considering what's going on with the
freedom convoys i think it's funny you
mentioned garcia saying bang pots and
pans
because when the when when the truckers
honked their horns it was the apocalypse
but they want you to come out and bang
pots and pans when it's their protest so
we'll get into all that stuff thanks for
hanging out we got ian he's chilling
what up everybody hey jorge glad you're
here man so i from time to time bring
this up because you guys did a lot of
work on the border and
which means
deliveries i believe it means and this
is this was around the wrist of a child
yeah the last time we were here we were
to show you guys those bracelets those
are the bracelets that you that uh
migrants are being are have basically
forced to wear by these human smugglers
down in south texas so we just wanted to
show the american people that these
migrants are being used as essentially
just products for drug cartels human
smuggling groups according to some
reports that we got um human smugglers
right now are making up to 14 million
dollars a day just off human smoking
we're not even talking about the
fentanyl that's coming into the country
yet we've got we got immigration stories
as well with what's going on i mean it's
kind of crazy what's happening with
ukraine a lot of people are upset
because our own borders and being isn't
being protected but we'll get into all
that stuff we got liddy pressing all the
time i am also here in the corner
pushing buttons very excited to have
jorge and sognik back we always enjoy
having them they always bring the on the
ground reporting from wherever they go
and we appreciate their presence and we
also uh for some reason there's a
vagrant sitting in the back of the room
oh yeah look at this guy look at this
beanie wearing can you see it
wild pink t-shirt wearing it's richie
mcginnis yeah baby
mcginnis yeah
yes he is no one can oh here you come
here bring it back here he comes
i'm a beer catty and uh i have the right
to remain silent it's true he does
richie mcginnis ladies and gentlemen
matthew mcconaughey
he's trapped here though so we got him
in earlier all right everybody before we
get started we do have an amazing
sponsor it is biotrusts ageless
multi-collagen just had two stronger
bones in life you can get your ageless
multi-collagen 51 off this stuff is
essential for your joint your joints
your hair your skin your nails now uh
today we were out skating and if you
guys watched the vlog we set up a six
and a half foot tall like what is it 20
feet long air bag landing so that we
could be doing front flips and well not
just any kind of crazy flips off this
ramp we were towing people on an
electric motorbike so uh naturally as
we're all actually uh we're actually
quite old to be doing something like
this because we're in our 30s we're
going to need to make sure we supplement
with this ageless multi-collagen i
actually have some here in my fancy red
drink i have every day go to
strongerbonesandlife.com and you can get
fifty one percent off a sixty day money
back guarantee the healthy aging support
of collagen in its ideal forms five key
types of collagen you need from four
different sources for every order today
biotrust will donate a nutritious meal
to a hungry child in your honor through
their partnership with no kid hungry.org
to date biotrust has provided over 5
million meals to hungry kids please help
biotrust hit their goal of 6 million
meals this year it is non-gmo and free
of artificial colors flavors
preservatives and sweeteners free of
gluten antibiotics and rbgh in rbst
nearly no odor or taste there's no
clumping unlike other supplements and
you'll get free shipping with every
order free vip live health and fitness
coaching from biotrust's team of expert
nutrition and health coaches for life
with every order and their free e-report
the 14 foods for amazing skin with every
order again stronger bones in life.com
special thank you to biotrust for being
a direct sponsor of the show putting
their name front and center so that
everybody who hates us gets to see that
we have awesome support from companies
that like what we do and appreciate our
viewers supporting their company as well
but don't forget go to timcast.com
become a member you can also support our
work directly we're going to have a
special members only segment coming up
around 11 or so p.m for all of our
members but as a member you're keeping
all of our journalists employed we don't
we don't rely heavily on sponsorship for
the most part we do for the website rely
on people being members and we have a
lot of members you guys make it all
possible we're eternally grateful for
that so don't forget smash that like
button like button one like is one honk
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends let's talk about this
first big story this is crazy
from al jazeera trudeau lifts emergency
order invoked to end trucker protests
amid criticism the canadian pm insists
emergencies act was needed to quell
anti-government blockades and occupation
speaking to reporters on wednesday
afternoon trudeau said the emergencies
act was necessary to help law
enforcement agencies disperse large
numbers of protesters who had descended
on ottawa we get it but it's not true
it's absolutely not true they could have
had a very small group of police
officers very small
walk up to the peaceful truckers and say
we're placing you under arrest for you
know obstructing a roadway and that's it
we've seen them do this over and over
again to climate change activists to
lifting protesters i understand canada's
a different country than the u.s but
come on policing is very similar here
and there instead they pulled out the
boot and they put it on people's necks
my opinion is that they wanted to make
these emergency powers permanent we
already heard the deputy prime minister
in canada say we want this this you know
financial powers to be permanent because
of cryptocurrencies and and crowdfunding
and now all of a sudden oh we're lifting
the order why i think the backlash was
bad they they wanted to use the protest
as an excuse to expand their powers it
didn't work
well i don't know what's going to happen
next
certainly they did crush those protests
we got protests coming here into the u.s
they're trying to unfreeze bank accounts
but i'll throw it to you guys i mean
you've you guys have been on the ground
for a lot of protests i don't know if
you guys were following what was
happening with the truckers up in canada
or at you know similar protests but i'm
curious what your thoughts are based on
what you've seen on the ground
versus what's displayed in the news i
think for me the biggest takeaway was
this is one of the biggest
worker uprisings that we've ever seen in
our history where you actually have true
you know people in the middle class
working class actually up rising
together and it's not like a fringe left
or fringe right it's just a true working
class coming together then you actually
got to see the canadian government how
they responded with just complete
government overreach using their
security forces to beat up on protesters
to beat up on also members of the media
a lot of members of the rebel news which
i'm i'm really truly grateful for for
rebel news because their journalists
have been on the ground and just getting
us these crucial videos um of what's
going on in ottawa and without them i
feel like we would be just kind of be um
you know depending on the corporate
media and the way actually i look at
rebel news is actually i look at um our
dc riot squad in 2020 where it's like
you kind of have these few on the ground
reporters getting these kind of viral
videos and showing you the truth um but
i think one of the biggest takeaways
from what's going on in canada was that
you know governments all over
have been completely silent when it
comes to violence on peaceful protesters
and also members of the media um i think
one of the the key takeaways that i've
took away is that at least the president
of el salvador naibu kelly has come out
and spoken out against this and it's
it's it's interesting to see because for
me as well as you know these
demonstrations were happening in you
know in yemen or afghanistan or anything
like that the us government will be
quickly you know up in arms and telling
us how we need to intervene but since
it's canada i mean we've been completely
silent on this issue didn't didn't uh
canada issue a statement about cuba
recently like during the protest did you
see that something like that where
they're like people should have their
free speech like shut up nobody believes
you you know what's really fascinating
about this though the craziest thing is
for me to see you mention this in the
intro that garcetti is like bang your
pots and pans for the first responders
and i'm like you mean be a public
nuisance and keep people up at night no
no i i don't really care about the the
pots and pans what what do they call
that they call it the casserole's prices
yeah i don't mind that i don't care if
people are banging pots and pans i'll go
and be like whoo make some noise but
they complain about the truckers honking
their horns
now i get it i'll say it all the time
different countries
but the same people in the u.s who are
supporting banging pots and pans and
protesting with black lives matter
during a pandemic are condemning
truckers for going out and protesting
speaking of like protests uh the trucker
protest is like a perfect example of
what a peaceful demonstration looks like
and
the whole cause and effect is just to
cause a disruption so that people in
charge realize that
though like we are essential to what you
do and how the country works and if we
stop working there's a huge problem
so you as our ruler are kind of
responsible to take care of what our
needs and demands is because like you
are in charge of us well and we vote you
we watch you guys in i take my cues from
alexandria ocasio-cortez she's a great
leader she's a thought leader for our
generation and she says that protests
are are supposed to make you
uncomfortable right yeah i i say you're
you're so right you're so brilliant
i absolutely agree
no but but also i'm comfortable in all
seriousness so she she is right the
problem is the protests she was
offending were violent
riotous
and
the ones we're defending are like people
parking their trucks in the street and
honking
yeah i wonder if they would have had a
better protest if they weren't honking
if they just blocked traffic and sat
there and stopped working because like
you want to make people uncomfortable
but it's the kind of discomfort we're
like uh oh if the truckers aren't there
we're gonna suffer not the kind of
discomfort where like it hurts because
you're making so much noise stop because
now most of those people in ottawa
wanted the truckers gone they're
downtown though it's like they're going
into suburbs in like residential
neighborhoods it's worse downtown
because you have buildings with just
densely packed uh citizens that are
suffering basically it's not a
residential area though
there i've seen a video of people like
in their high rises reporting from
people who live there i'm not saying
nobody lives there but it's not like
they're going into a strictly
residential neighborhood they're going
into like downtown i understand the
intent to disrupt and blockade and just
and to i get that part but it's the
noises was really destructive probably
unnecessarily destructive so so american
guys you truckers keep that in mind
they're looking for a reason to bust you
don't give them oh everyone's posting
one's in chat no no no no no
honking
honking i think is brilliant me too uh
it's it's it's you're just honking your
horn you're making noise these
protesters go around with boom boxes
they go around screaming they go around
chanting they bang drums non-stop this
is what protests have have been doing
for a really really long time to come
out now and be like oh but the truckers
shouldn't i'm like
look we tolerate a certain degree of of
discomfort for for non-violent civil
disobedience and making noise can be
annoying and frustrating but it really
does show you the the complete bs
that is the left right paradigm that
when you are making noise in their city
how dare you oh i'm gonna go and enact
emergency powers and freeze your banks
yet they they can go out and they can
bang whatever they want whenever they
want for their cause that when you're
when you're engaging in your protest on
the steps of your state capitol building
they say oh it's a super spreader event
these evil far right guys and then they
go up by the thousands during the same
pandemic and the nurses are clapping and
cheering from i love that photo where
the nurse is standing in front of the
truck that says like no mandates or
whatever and they're like you know
hands on their hips and then at the same
time you get a video of nurses clapping
for black lives matter i'm like dude i'm
not playing this stupid you get you know
rules for the but not for me game if if
if we tolerate
banging from the left and pots and pans
i got no issue with people honking i
wouldn't tolerate it outside my house if
people were making noise 24 7 i wouldn't
tolerate it i'd make it stop and if the
law wasn't well there's lots of ways to
do it no there isn't yeah one of them is
called the cops
right and then noise ordinances and
stuff for a reason so you support the
the emergency powers to crack down and i
think they could the fact that they
could do that and do it again tomorrow
if they wanted to spin them up again is
terrifying and we should repeal the
patriot act that they could use the in
the ndi
i mean for me it's hard to fault the
truckers at all i mean the honking's not
a big deal i guess for me from my
perspective is just from being on the
ground and seeing the black lives matter
protest in person you know you had folks
in i mean there was a famous aerial shot
in dc where almost it looked like every
single building was on fire you had
people in dc and their high rises where
they're filming videos like actually
cheer on the protest and as soon as the
protesters look at them they'll like
throw a rock through the window so for
me it's like you know the honking i
can't fault um especially what we've
seen on the ground here in the united
states and the thing is the media that's
demonizing the truckers i mean they're
all in cities that were being wrecked by
the black lives matter protests in in
2020. yeah so i may disagree with ian
about um whether or not the trucker
should have been honking but i do think
he has a salient point about the feds
now keeping a very close eye on the
truckers jack pacobic also made the
point recently he said i don't think
that a convey is the best way to get
your point across he said i think that a
general strike is a better way to do it
yeah i think that's true because it is
so decentralized there's something we
talk a lot about i think something so
decentralized would really drive the
point home look at this video real quick
such a great video look at this video
this is a video from the black lives
matter insurrection in washington dc
look at the smoke everywhere
it's it's it's absolutely insane i i
would never forget that image i remember
that image always yeah that always
sticks out my sister she owns a wine bar
downtown dc and the day after this she
sent me photos of her glasses and she
has like plants outside the bar and
everything was shattered and stuff like
that and even if like i was to like step
myself out of the bubble and be like hey
is this dangerous or are truckers
blocking downtown and honking dangerous
i would rather i don't know i would
choose the one where my sister's bar
glasses got shattered
right right right we're gonna see this
freedom convoy there's two there's the
people there's there's actually several
there's more than two people's convoy is
going to be leaving i think they left
today they live today from um are lonzo
california yeah which is in san
bernardino county and they're planning
on making it to dc by the fifth yeah but
there's also the freedom yeah yeah it's
crazy and they're going to be there on
the first so i guess they're driving a
lot more so basically starting march
there's going to be like a lot of
truckers a lot of people basically all
over the dmv area
yeah making this same point
we
we're super close to frederick which is
like the last and it's not just that now
now dc is again back to the green zone
which it was after gen 6 which is kind
of makes me really sad because i've been
living in dc for like three years now
and the city was all fine and dandy
before i don't know like covet and after
cover it happened and john 6 happened
the city turned into a green zone and it
was all sad and gloomy and downtown you
can like hear on like a needle drop
and it was kind of getting better and
starting i don't know like yesterday
it's again like getting locked up and
yeah it feels like a symbolic protest
this this going to dc and setting up in
the capital like it's it's more it's not
a functional protest it doesn't actually
do anything
you're wrong it's just wrong it's like
look how look at how big i am
i'm bigger than you i control the world
now and the feds are gonna be like no
you don't bro and i'm gonna show you how
you don't let's address this and first i
want to give us we got a story here
breaking down a little bit what we got
usa today reports truck convoy nearing
nation's capital pentagon okay's use of
national guard vaccination drive stalls
as omicron fades covet updates as many
as 700 national guard are prepared to
take posts across the nation's capital
amid planned trucker protest convoys
that organizers say could paralyze the
city without entering it bob bolas a
pennsylvania truck driver says he's
leading the freedom convoy of trucks
from pennsylvania to washington on
wednesday but he told nbc 4 in
washington that he has backed off
immediate plans to gridlock the capital
we're not shutting the traffic down
today if we don't have a resolution from
the uh from the government to the rights
that they're taking from us i will
predict in the future it will get shut
down
so you've got there's this pennsylvania
convoy coming from the north you've got
the people's convoy coming from
california i think freedom convoy is
also california right correct and
there's also one coming from maryland
and the guy he's running for governor in
maryland he's also there but like
there's some like iffyness because like
it's just one truck and his tires got
slashed so many things happen at one
time interesting so i think these
protests are incredibly effective nay
ian i believe they may be the most
effective we've seen in our lifetimes
because i've i've seen many and perhaps
you could argue the george floyd riots
got a lot done for black lives matter
yeah but those are riots not protests
and we know the establishment has been
defending and supporting these violent
extremists
in terms of a protest you look at what
happened in ottawa
boy did that generate press it made the
issue of border vaccines the number one
story which is it's important the
squeaky wheel gets the grease which is
why non-violent civil disobedience works
when you go out and you stage a
disruptive protest you'll get a slap on
the wrist you'll get arrested and i
think you should because you're crossing
a line but it's a line we say okay okay
we get it you wanted people to hear you
all of a sudden the news says hey that
disruption it was because of this
so if you look at the ottawa protests
how many people were talking about
vaccine mandates on the border not a
whole lot the truckers get in their
trucks they drive to ottawa and all of a
sudden for three or four weeks one of
the one of the biggest stories
internationally was this trudeau was
forced to to i don't think he was
necessarily forced to i don't think they
need to use emergency powers but the
mask slips now we can see
you've got you've got regular people
saying this is fascism this is martial
law it has exposed the despotism of
these of this establishment one grain of
sand at a time i'm not going to pretend
like there's a revolution overnight from
truckers honking their horns but people
can see the double standard they can see
the the bs hierarchy we call it now not
hypocrisy that the left gets away with
this stuff and the right gets punished
for it and you can see the lengths
they're willing to go to maintain power
that's the main thing because like no
one would have ever expected that
trudeau would just invoke a terrorism
clause just like that
just to get a hold of how people are
supporting these truckers like just
think about that for a fact like
to think about the fact that this
the thing which they did in terms of
like freezing the bank accounts and even
to reach as far as the crypto stuff
like the fact that trudeau went that far
i think that just credits the truckers
that without them putting this
up front and center no one would have
guessed that the prime minister could go
as far as to getting a hold of your
personal bank account i think that they
would invoke terrorism stuff because of
the violence because of the noise and
and
roll ones all you want guys but noises
can be violent you can kill someone with
too much noise terrorism though that
that has terrorism by definition has
like a political motive to it
i think that they were trying to scare
people or this is the mentality of what
they're going to say they're trying to
scare people to get their politics
accomplished
the scenario right now a fascist
dictatorship will use this argument and
say your honking is violent you are
aggressing on the people and we're going
to invoke whatever we need to stop and
that is exactly why it was an effective
protest because any sane rational person
is hearing that going what yeah just
talking about what you're talking about
but when you're there yeah i thought it
was just
until i watched a video of a guy that
lives there and it's like okay it's not
just honking like it's it's non-stop all
day i mean it's gonna be you know not
comfortable but i agree with sonic's
take where i think what happened in
ottawa actually exposed the canadian
government because i think we've all you
know all of us were like hey they
wouldn't go that far then we saw the
freezing of the bank accounts then we
saw the videos of these police officers
rolling up to these truckers just
busting out their windows then we saw
the viral footage of that disabled woman
trampled by the horse so i think that
actually did was actually really
effective in exposing the canadian
government because we never knew that
they could be that authoritarian i mean
up to my my concern is if you want to
expose the american government in its
fascist ways
okay but if you hold a piece of meat out
in front of a hungry wolf and it bites
your hand yeah you exposed it for being
the dumb idiot animal that it was but at
what was the cost of the exposition i
don't i don't need to sacrifice a bunch
of truckers to prove that what do you
mean the fascist dictatorship has taken
over our government 100 years ago what
do you mean by sacrifice i don't want to
see people go to solitary to try and
just to prove that biden's in the hand
of klaus schwab or some
you know
like the federal reserve it's so fascist
this whole system we're
we don't need to hurt ourselves to prove
this right now we need to fix it
fascistic i think is the better word you
know you know what i don't like about
people saying communism and fascism is
that they're they're they represent no
they represent 100 years ago when we had
this these rising ideologies in europe
they were specific now we've got a lot
of technology that has changed how it's
being implemented and
when you know trudeau and biden and they
use these authoritarian powers it's like
fash commu fascism it's it's weird they
saw what there's a meme where they fold
the political compass authoritarian
right you know and left over it's like
whatever china is doing yeah it's like
yeah no exactly it's like a weird new
thing but i will respond to you ian
by saying
we don't want violence
violence doesn't work because the
establishment preys upon it when when
you look at january 6th it was
everything the democrats and
and the neocon never trumpers wanted
because now they could justify
everything and we've got a system of
laws that say oh you got violent we got
you now the truckers it was amazing they
were annoying they were annoying that
was it people were annoyed by them the
people a lot of people weren't annoyed
by it they were just like dancing in the
street they were having a good time
what happens though is the powerful
elites don't know how to deal with it
because you're not doing anything it's
like going outside of someone's house
and just protests yelling it's like
you're allowed to do it well but the
noise violations so you gotta be careful
like i do support a bunch of quite
a silent protest which a bunch of trucks
just stopped in the roads for miles that
would be and you also have to think
about the protesters like these truckers
have been through so much have been
through all these crazy mandates and now
they're seeing that anytime they cross
you know into canada they're
technically this like electronic qr code
you know for them enough is enough and
i don't think honking is the worst thing
in the world not just that
like as journalists we focus on
narrative imagery binaries like think
about the imagery of the state of the
union going on and god bless biden
speechwriters because i don't know what
he's going to talk about that
but state of the union going on and at
the same time all these truckers outside
the capital just blocking everything
so that's like um
that's an optic that's a binary in front
of you right there whatever like biden
cooks up at that speech i don't know
what he will but there are people who
are just literally saying stop this
stuff we need to go back to what it was
can you can you imagine if like for the
state of the union joe biden just comes
out 100 honest and he's like in my first
year i my policies have driven massive
inflation high gas prices where we have
a new war reforming in eastern europe
afghanistan was a mess they chose me to
be here in the first place
fentanyl crisis killing america unless
you're praying right there so like dude
but i would love him if he did that
i agree if he came out and actually was
just like totally honest with everything
i respect it yeah i'd be like wow yeah
like i think i think that would actually
in in in some respect make him one of
the best presidents we've ever had for
just coming out and laying bare
everything i might be getting too old
for this job too
i need you guys to know that i i'm not
who i use sorry for me to talk
i'm there with you joe i want to go to
bed yeah why am i here
so i i will respond i will respond to
your point though ian those who make
peace uh peaceful revolution impossible
make violent revolution inevitable
kennedy they do that and you
fact-checked that for me the other day
yeah and gandhi
yeah and yeah i mean to be honest yeah
the gandhi protests but even even black
lives matter like if they like for
example this is an example let's just
say they brought a hundred thousand
people
to you know the the capital non-violent
protests peaceful demonstration they
actually would have got a lot more done
i mean fast forward to this year black
lives matter i mean to to be honest they
really haven't gotten much done the only
people that have really benefited are
the founders like patrice colors who are
now richer than ever got deals with levi
got deals with youtube got you know
buying mansions in malibu um but
everyone else hasn't got anything from
it i mean there's literally local groups
all over the country if you guys look it
up that are very angry with black lives
matter because they didn't do anything
to actually fund their movement we even
have um
some people that um some mothers and
fathers speaking out who's had their you
know son or daughter killed by police
who said hey black lives matter came and
all they did was just griff like
literally they got rich and we didn't
even see a dollar back into the
community so even black lives matter
with their violent protest even though
the media was on their side they
technically didn't get anything
accomplished yeah and you got to
understand we're dealing with this like
overarching culture war black lives
matter had for a long time corporate
support institutionalized support the
vice president supporting while they're
burning down buildings and quite
literally killing people aaron danielson
killed in portland by an antifa guy you
had the antifa guy firebomb the ice
facility you had 30 plus dead in the in
the george floyd riots and they still
receive institutional support and then
along comes some truckers and they honk
their horns and everybody loses their
minds and so i'm like yo i can tolerate
honking and i think the fact
it really is to me just so perfect to
show regular people when they're like
uh yeah my business was destroyed last
uh you know not last year but the year
before from the george floyd writes why
are you complaining to me and using
emergency powers over some guy honking
his horn it's a slap in the face to the
average person whose lives were
destroyed that you're going to have
someone come out and they're going to be
like noises violence so we're going to
crush you and freeze your banks they do
that the mask comes off and you're going
to have a lot of regular people
although i will admit i don't know how
many people are uninitiated at this
point but there's gonna be a lot of
people questioning
what what's going on correct like in a
bubble
like in the news bubble in the politics
bubble it may seem like pretty mundane
to us that people oh i hate the mandate
oh i hate the vaccine i hate masks but
if you think about it a normal people
saying like throw on the word normie
like who doesn't care about all this and
he just comes across like the dmv and
all these truckers are clogging up and
he starts asking the question hey what's
up what's going on why are these people
here and that kind of like
sparks the discourse within that
community and then they realize that oh
hey maybe the shelves are empty why are
the shelves empty because the truckers
are not bringing stuff across why the
truckers not doing that because they
hate the mandates hey what's up with the
mandates but let's let's let's
make one more point for you
when everybody goes out and smashes and
destroys things for the black for the
george floyd riots
people on the right
people who are not even on the right who
had their businesses destroyed they're
they're furious and all of a sudden now
they are gifted an emotional release
that has no long-term damage correct
they honk their horn and they feel
better they get to express themselves
and it kind of can help things
depressurize because if you tell these
people they're not even allowed to be
noisy while the other other rioters
destroyed everything then you're going
to make violent revolution inevitable
when people lose their minds i i could
see how what you're you guys are saying
like maybe that getting the wolf to snap
at your hand and grab at the food is
important to show people like hey it's
not a puppy dog it's a wolf and wake
people up that way like the the 1970 may
4th kent state shooting vietnam protest
a bunch of students were out there and
then they're throwing rocks at the
national guard national guard opened
fire and killed four people um and that
shocked the country into awareness
basically brought about the end of
vietnam war more or less you know the
song that was written about it was
powerful too ohio uh by crosby stills
nation young
so maybe but i don't want to see a bunch
of people's lives get destroyed by some
stupid patriot act
you're right you're right and i think
it's their choice to make
and i also always want to say man you
know i mentioned other people get that
emotional release from it but i gotta
admit me having watched years a decade
of rioting
and the right never comes out in
protests and then finally when they do
for issues of freedom they get demonized
it feels good for me when i when i watch
truckers is going honk honk when i'm
tweeting the word honk in all caps the
the people are saying the cure for clown
world is honking well it's just like
it it feels good to be able to have
something it feels good no we don't want
to get violent i don't i think violence
is bad i don't want to see people get
hurt but man is it frustrating to see
the extremists on the left do all of
this stuff and get away with it and have
the media lie and cover up for them and
then you know what gets that you know
what happens i watch some truckers piss
up piss all of these people off by
honking no long-term damage to these
people no one's getting hurt they're
just getting frustrated and angry and it
feels good at the very least like thank
you we we we've expressed our outrage to
you that frustration we've had it allows
people to laugh about it and i think
it's important yeah one of the best
parts too uh i think with the tucker i
mean with this whole trucker protest is
that it actually exposes those who on
the left who say that they're supposed
to be pro-worker you know remember let's
not forget the left and the progressive
movement they're supposed to be the side
on the worker the middle class and
actually i was i was telling some some
some people that hey when me and sonic
produces 0-0 documentary if you would
watch this in the early 2000s or the
early 90s you would have thought
liberals produced it right because we
were taking the side of the worker going
against big pharma going against big
corporations so
what's happening with the truckers and
the optics of the truckers it's also
exposing those in the left and the media
who say that they are pro-worker or
they're on the side of the little man
well now the little man's protesting and
they're still being uh demonized so i
think that's actually kind of the best
things to look for and also we've never
really seen the trucker movement ever
uprising like that right so like the
black lives matter that's more young
people you know maybe these anti-vaccine
mandate stuff earlier where like hey
these people are fringe right but these
truckers are just regular folks i mean
you know really you know my dad's a
trucker you know so it's a guy that
literally goes into his truck works 16
hours a day doesn't see his family for
two to three months i mean these people
are the true working class well so so
let's talk about your uh your
documentary you've got uh like the
truckers you had these people who are
considered essential they were heroes it
was it was not just medical workers it
was truckers it was first responders it
was
firemen but it was also people working
at retail stores right yeah then these
mandates come out they fire the nurses
they they mock the truckers and like you
guys covered they they fire the first
responders it's not just like the firing
of it it's more about the dichotomy of
like two years ago
you and i don't know maybe rightly so
you held up
the hey these are our heroes and also
which i would surprise you with while
talking to a bunch of the nurses they
were like
actually personally i never liked being
called hero
and stuff like that because like that
like that's what i do for a living like
the fact that they're acknowledging it
right now kind of makes me makes me
really suspicious that by labeling us
hero right now they already are starting
off with the political motive so that's
one thing which i noticed and the second
thing was like yeah that was like two
years ago and now the same people who
just said that hey it's my personal
choice i don't want to i don't want the
vaccine right now
they were really cut off point blank and
not only that there are like so many
real little minutiaes here and the
nurses they had to wear different badges
in their hospitals like a pink badge or
like a yellow badge to let people know
that hey i'm not vaccinated
which kind of invokes uh like it's it's
super subtle like if you think about it
like they're wearing a pink badge while
everyone else is wearing their gen like
the the default badge because like
someone might come up to you and ask you
hey why are you wearing a pink batch
then you
by nature of the conversation are kind
of forced to let people know that i'm
not vaccinated which kind of like
infringes on your personal boundary so
all there are so many little things
which no one talks about but two years
ago these are the same people
firefighters and cops
the thing that means sonic talked about
was you know we were surprised we're
like hey where's these you know
progressive journalists they're supposed
to be doing this the daily caller isn't
supposed to be taking the pro worker
site technically it's supposed to be the
progressive movement and one of the
firefighters that that we interviewed
that stands out to me is josh sadly josh
sally is a firefighter for the beverly
hills fire department since october 1st
josh sally has been placed on unpaid
leave till today hasn't received a
paycheck he has a family of four we me
and son got to meet his wife and kids
and he hasn't uh received a paycheck um
the city has him in limbo as of right
now he's on pace to be the first
firefighter fired in southern california
for not taking the vaccine and these are
the stories that we wanted to tell the
american people say hey these are real
people you know i know you guys watch
the la times and things like that and
they've been demonized as these q and
honors or anti-factors these are are you
know real americans and at the same time
the l.a times was was praising these
same people just a year or two years ago
so we wanted to give them a voice and it
kind of ties down to you know it ties to
this trucker movement where the regular
uh you know
average or working-class citizen has
been demonized from the media i mean
since basically the beginning of the
pandemic obviously you guys know 2020
the greatest transfer of wealth the
poorer we got poorer the richer got
richer and it just seems like the
working class doesn't have any voice and
and really in any any media space right
now i mean you turn on msnbc they were
demonizing cheering i mean for me i
think the the part that was most i guess
shocking was just seeing uh these
progressives what they call themselves
or people on the left cheering on the
firing of workers i mean they're the
first of all if a firefighter gets
placed on unpaid leave the progressive
woman's supposed to be the first ones to
say hey wait a minute why is this worker
being placed on unpaid leave with no
type of you know core or date um so it's
for me that's been the most shocking
part of how no one wants to give first
responders a voice and i highly
encourage anyone in the audience please
watch the documentary it's called hero
to zero
we have our own website for it so it's
hero to zero doc dot com like that we
could avoid any time of youtube center
and please share these stories because
like this week at least combat uh that
mainstream narrative i was thinking
about how it's challenging for blue
collar workers to have a voice it seems
like in society and it's almost like
it's built that way because if a blue
collar worker starts a youtube channel
and starts getting notoriety all of a
sudden they're white collar they're now
they're making money off their youtube
channel and they don't need to do their
other job anymore and so like
it seems like the nature of of giving a
voice to anyone makes them white collar
the thing is to it ian is 90 of the
media is owned by these six large
corporations so anytime you even want to
start to tell real stories about
americans i mean those you know those
journals get cut off really quick you
know they say hey wait a minute we don't
want you telling that story we want you
to fall right back in line and and do
this and the thing is the problem with
uh media in dc and new york is these
folks are stuck in their own media
bubbles i mean a lot of the a lot of
these journalists and and that live in
washington dc they don't know anyone who
lost a business during the shutdowns
they don't know anyone's kids who fell
under the depression or suicidal
underscore shutdown so they can never
relate to an average american i think
that's been my biggest takeaway yeah i
can attest to that personally i live in
dc i'm in the quran called journalism
bubble politics like i usually like hang
around in like the capital hillary or
downtown area but i live in dc
but if and only when i travel for work
or for documentary purposes and i go to
all these places where all these
working-class people live it's also
like so apparent to me that these people
like the
it's so bizarre to me it looks
completely different take a look at this
story from 2018.
it's from geekwire clash at amazon hq
construction workers shout down council
members over planet tax big business i
love this because these construction
workers are the actual working class
correct they have
their laborers they do work they build
they maintain the infrastructure these
are the people who make the machine you
know run on time
and the people protesting amazon are
leftist bourgeois
intelligentsia acting like they're the
working class
and this is what i think you guys what
you're working on it really exposes this
this documentary when they when they
come out they say oh we support the
first responders it's just hunger games
it's hungry it's when it's when they
parade around the victors and act like
they care about these people they don't
and then finally when those people tell
them i don't want to do what you're
telling me all of a sudden it's war all
of a sudden you're the problem i love
this video construction workers and hard
hats started chanting down
the leftist college
you know faux working-class people
really exposed well one thing to tim
really quick is uh during 2020 one thing
that i try to speak out is in 2020
amazon i mean for for amazon this was
brilliant you know amazon all they have
to do in 2020 is just you know if you go
shop on amazon on their on their website
all they have to put is oh black lives
matter and all of a sudden the
progressive movement who's supposed to
be pro worker are like wait a minute
amazon's on our side you just you know
they say black lives matter yet their
own black employees can't even pay their
their wage or their bills you know they
have to live in their cars their own
black employees don't have any health
care um so that's one thing also these
corporations have figured out is hey as
long as we play this social justice
message we no longer have to attend to
the to the pro-worker policies that the
left wants those are called platitudes i
believe
corporations offer platitudes i think
it's i think the activists left are
basically some of this uh
this country's elite they really are i
know there's a lot of college debt don't
get me wrong but a lot of these people
are uh the highest salary earners in the
country correct the college uh people
with college degrees have have on
average the highest salaries they're
just angry they're not billionaires but
i you know what uh when i think about
like around here this organization
obviously what you do is the most
important aspect here but it's ben
townsend the most blue collar he's the
guy that fixes machines can can code
your computer for you can like fix your
computer like that's elite keeps things
running yeah the people who are working
behind the scenes to make sure the
infrastructure is operational those are
the working class people not the intel
like if i were to come out and be like i
i think it's it's unfair what these
people are doing i should get more the
government should give me subsidies and
abolish my debt it'd be like what that's
ridiculous it's the thing which like the
country has moved in towards a point
where people who work in the
quote-unquote information economy only
they will be
catered to like if you work with your
hands and stuff like that you are not
part of the conversation like being like
the whole trucker protest will never be
as cool as black lives matter is like
people will not put black lives matter
people will not put sorry uh the trucker
symbol as their profile photos as they
put black lives matter there's not gonna
be a freedom trucker plaza in dc correct
they're not going to spray freedom
convoy on the ground maybe in 80 years
but could you imagine i want you to
imagine something real quick i want you
to imagine being a buzzfeed employee
getting paid 50 or 60 thousand dollars a
year to write listicles and then go hmm
i'm oppressed huh yeah my it's unfair i
deserve more meanwhile i just you know
you know what's funny is because
for me you know where i grew up the way
i've lived my life the people i met
i was never surrounded by these ivory
tower elites of new york city and that's
the thing about journalists that these
these people tend to be especially in
new york
well off
from families who are moderately
well-off they get access to colleges
colleges they many of them have debt for
sure
but the reason
so so here's what happens with these
with these uh media jobs in order to get
a job in new york working in media
because they pay so little to start
correct you need your parents for the
most part to subsidize you exactly and
so what happens is all of these news
organizations are basically trust fund
kids or something to that effect and
then they're sitting there look i i got
to tell you man there are people who
work at buzzfeed who get paid 50 60
grand a year
50 imagine getting paid 30 to 40 an hour
to write about
a list of 10 cats that have funny faces
and then to say i'm oppressed yo i got
some dirt that needs tilling so we can
eat food tomorrow why don't you come and
shovel it and learn what work is
now and then um if you remember last
year
me and
you know all these other reporters that
were on the front end we got attacked by
the intercept and the big the big my
biggest takeaway was like wait a minute
so we're getting attacked by a
journalist who just sits in his
manhattan apartment who has been given a
job because his parents were in ivy
league to reporters who are on the
ground actually uh talking about the
destruction to working class communities
i'm like i'm like that's actually media
right there that's that you know it's
just it's just a great round of how it's
these uh you know elite journalists
who've really never had a work hard mom
and dad knows everyone in the in the
industry and then they get in and they
make like you said 50 to 60k 70k just
sitting in a manhattan apartment and the
thing is they're not even on the ground
reporting they're just reporting from
their laptop that's why they love the
lock downs because they can have wine
wine wine delivery ubereats and then i
love it when they're like help help i'm
being harassed on social media it's like
oh too bad
yeah man it's it's we we've got
it's it's crazy what the internet has
done and we didn't expect this but this
is one of the things it's done it's all
of these journalists create these online
groups and they all talk to each other
and they they're they're the epitome of
ego that's what it is they all think
they're the most important people in the
world it's their job to tell people what
to think and what to believe they think
they are the most important people in
the world and they they look down on on
on the trades they look down on working
class people they look down on the
people who actually do the jobs to make
this machine work they think it's them
like even if they like
like i don't know like to play the
devil's advocate like i would think like
they would probably think differently if
they like you know traveled or like went
outside dc new york california and
actually met people they're probably
good people but they just haven't met
anyone else who doesn't partake in the
information economy or the creator
economy i somewhat disagree i mean i
understand what you mean by they're good
people i think they could be good people
yeah but i do want to differentiate
there are journalists real ones who
travel around go on the ground interview
people you know obviously we have
journalists at timcast.com they're not
this i mean a lot of them they're you
know we're living out in west virginia
so we understand what work looks like
and there's a lot of journalists who
actually go to these foreign countries
go to brazil go to morocco or whatever
talk to people and see what the world is
like and they get it but we have this
issue now where the money is to be made
in
flashy click bait listicles and 10
reasons to hate donald trump and why
donald trump is a fascist and that's the
kind of media they produce so they sit
in new york like you guys mentioned
they're in their apartment they don't
even go to work half the time and they
just type away here's why i think
trump's stupid and they get paid to do
it they call themselves journalists when
half the time it's opinion
yeah roosevelt quote i think that great
minds talk about ideas mediocre minds
talk about things and weak minds talk
about people i find that i've kind of
engraved that into my soul i get almost
guilty talking about people like what a
waste why are we wasting our time with
this low this low quality conversation
but i also i took it so extreme that i
stopped completely uh talking about
people and that's a mistake because we
need to gossip about each other's egos
if we're gonna manage society it's a
bunch of egos together keep each other
in check but it is not the focus and
when i see cnn making it the focus
that's when i'm like no no that's why i
don't even watch it and so and sometimes
i come off ignorant on this show when we
talk about what they said i don't care
what i mean
i i i want to unders i want to know what
they said but it is not it's it's really
dumb people talking about dumb stuff
i'll give you an example of what i
really don't like and it's just me
personally i don't you know if you like
it by all means to you but you look at
some of these youtube channels
a lot of progressives even some
conservative and it's like just ragging
on someone like people making videos
specifically about you know this one guy
i don't like and naming him
within reason it's fine if you're
talking about joe biden the president or
congress you're talking about our system
of governance and the individuals who
have that power that i understand but
when it's like gossip you know what i
mean like you're like you're talking
about i'm not a fan of that stuff and
i'll give you an example the other day
we're talking about you know texts i get
from congress i'm not going to say their
names it's not them i care about as a
person it's it's the it's the idea of
what they're doing it's the actions
they're taking that i have an issue with
because the way i see it is
with even with joe biden you take joe
biden out of the presidency any democrat
can replace him and do the exact same
thing and that's a bad thing so we said
here if we if we put all our attention
on just joe biden why he's bad and then
we we you know he leaves and then booty
judge gets in it'll be the exact same
thing
no i completely agree and then i mean
just talking about the uh
the kind of click lady stuff a lot of
the kind of left-wing channels really
focus on like out you know hassan and
sam cedar you go on the channel it's all
about oh tim paul this temple said that
so one of the few people on the left
that actually respect and i think that
he's his what he's doing has been
crucial for the kind of movement on
waking up people is actually jimmy dore
i thought you know i'm thinking jimmy
dore's actually even though he you know
you know he calls himself a you know
democratic socialist or socialist he's
been on the right side of the issues
when it comes to free speech when it
comes to this accident these anti-um
vaccine mandate stuff he's he's telling
his his viewers he said hey guys if
you're true uh populist on the left then
you would never agree with any of his
stuff like it's supposed to be pro
worker to not take this out of the
corporations so he's actually one of the
few on that side that's that's that's on
the right side of this um he's honest
yeah not just that these progressive
creators and realize the pattern right
so they know uh what kind of content if
when i if and when i make
gets incentivized by youtube or twitch
whatever platform they're working with
right so
they know for a fact that if they
quote-unquote punch up right you know
punch up at temple punch up at uh joe
rogan for example they know that there's
no way that youtube's like not not gonna
like push that content up right so
they're kind of that that whole system
kind of it's like a feedback loop keeps
feeding itself the names become part of
the algorithm correct oh yeah absolutely
there was a really fascinating thing i
was reading i don't know i don't know
who was saying it maybe it was you they
said that uh they're watching a video
where a kid said they were playing like
fortnight and the kid said whoa he
almost just unalived me
and the reason the kids had unalived on
alive
is because if you say kill youtube down
ranks you and and hides your content oh
my gosh so kids are changing the way
they brainwashing humanity man that's
yes it is teaching kids to be counter
dependent on ideas is so so bad you need
to focus on the idea and then focus on a
different idea that's better than that
old one not on hating the old one i
think actually this would be a really
good idea we should we should task
someone with writing shadow english
a way to speak on youtube that bypasses
the algorithm that's like the plot of
1984
part of it there's like a second
dictionary dictionary to get monetized
yeah i can't say any any of the dodgy
words and all the words
yeah that's a good idea like that that
no none of the funny words exist on that
dictionary and then you're safe for your
whole life that your videos will make
money what if you're like this is the
new alphabet written by alphabet and
they'll put it into a new brought
i've been seeing a lot of political
youtubers like let's say you know
they're talking about something
controversial they always have to say at
the end of their controversial take hey
guys just want to let you know the cdc
says this and you know we're going to go
buy this i mean they only have to say
that to not get banned but that's where
we are right now in society i mean
youtube has
editorial guidelines you have to follow
i don't see how they should be protected
under section 230 if they issue
editorial guidelines they if if you
issue editorial guidelines then you are
certifying what is being published i
have a friend uh who runs a bodybuilding
channel and he was trying to
talk about arnold and he said arnold
schwarzenberg
no for real
you can't say his name
keemstar
had this had this issue happened where
he said the word and i'm going to be
very careful how i say it right
e
dash yeah girl
when you say that fast it sounds like
a type of n-word and he got d monetized
and he posts and he's like look at what
because the youtube caption system
had him saying
a specific because this auto generates
captions yeah so you don't know what
because it's
he said
hold on she said she's an
e
dash
girl now i get it and when you put that
all together very quickly
the youtube uh you know captioning
system thought that was
a racial slur so the caption is that the
official transcript of what the ai is
getting
i wouldn't i don't know if there's a
direct correlation between the ai that's
like i don't i don't know if the ai that
captions the word is the same that flags
the slurs
what is it going on what
camera on richie mcguinness ladies and
gentlemen gesticulating wildlife
if one recognizes the word the other
whether it's to say whether there's a
difference or not that i would imagine
it would flag it to the other program if
there's if there is another program it
might be the same one yeah another big
thing too was um on january 6 you had
kind of some you know left-wing
media groups like status cool where all
they did was actually just live stream
what happened on j6 like literally no
commentary no opinion like literally
just video
and youtube would demonetize their
account but then status quo would then
sell that same footage to like cnn and
msnbc fox news and then youtube will
prop up those accounts so that's that's
another thing too where it's like
they're also um aiming at independent
news channels whether you're left or
right they're coming after you and
that's that that was like one thing that
i i was pretty shocked by were like
status quo the same footage that they're
getting you know banned and getting
strikes on youtube they sell it to cnn
and then youtube props up you know cnn's
channel yep the same content they won't
know it on cnn's
status all they did was let me monetize
all they did was live stream i mean i'm
talking about no commentary no this and
that just straight video footage and you
know they obviously put it on youtube
because it's a moment in history and
then they sold it to abc news cnn msnbc
and they came and i said hey guys we're
getting banned and demonetized for the
same footage that we sold to the
mainstream guys but the mainstream guys
actually get propped up by youtube i'd
like to know in like a conversation with
youtube admins or google admins is it
that you believe cnn is is more valuable
and more legitimate or do you are you
just kind of like you know they're trash
anyway but you're just playing along
because that's where the money is ian
what was it you said yesterday that
everyone said you rolled a 20 on like
eight things the first one
number you said something about a
liberal economic order oh the liberal
economic order it's uh yeah and i looked
into that a little bit last night too
well i don't i don't want to go on a
tangent i'm just saying you know you're
asking a question about why cnn is being
propped up oh it's part of liberal
liberal international order the u.s
rules-based economy yeah could it be
that there is a cabal
that they created literally in 1946 that
eisenhower told us hey we created a
military-industrial complex fyi that's
why i love eisenhower because he like
just blatantly was honest about it
and almost like i'm so sorry yeah yeah
he was in order to prevent world war
three we're going to be the world police
now sorry hey look i don't let it get
out of hand because it's about to
imagine where we would be without
youtube and facebook and twitter though
to be honest whether it was intentional
or accidental whatever happened we using
the internet got a lot of voices were
able to to come up speak up gain access
get the microphone they may be freaking
out about it now but the cat's out of
the bag and i don't think they can they
can restrain it anymore i mean they're
trying really hard with censorship but
look at rumble the censorship is being
broken and people are finding a way
through satellite internet that's very
promising we'll be beaming video from
mars to earth and also where it's also
an interesting time in kind of
journalism and news because for the
first time ever i think in our history
the corporate press doesn't have total
control of the narrative and i thought
one of the biggest examples of that was
the kyle rittenhouse situation and you
know obviously i was getting you know
media requests with you know what fox
news and all these channels and anytime
i would go on i said obviously what's
going on with rittenhouse is a big case
for self-defense we know that i'm not
trying to understate that but in my
opinion i thought it was a bigger case
for how important that independent
journalism is because you know if it
wasn't for all those guys on the ground
on on on
you know then added kenosha where it was
julia rosa or bg on the scene or drew
hernandez
we would be stuck with the corporate
with the corporate media narrative and i
think for me the biggest uh thing that i
was shocked by was the amount of people
even during the rin house trial that
were that were contacting me or messing
with me saying holy i thought right now
has killed black people i just found out
that he didn't i'm like
that information's been up for a whole
year let me let me pull up this story
from abc news ladies and gentlemen i
give you ahmed arbory day that's right
holiday officially celebrating the
second anniversary of the death of ahmed
arbury february 23rd will permanently be
permanently recognized be permanently
recognized as ahmed arbory day in
georgia
they say the ahmed aubry foundation a
mental wellness organization focused on
black men that was founded by aubry's
mother wanda cooper jones announced the
nonprofit will offer six three thousand
dollar scholarships for higher education
opportunities to seniors from arbory's
former high school now i wanna start by
saying um that's fantastic if if they're
gonna give money for kids to
scholarships i'm not a big fan of
colleges or anything like that but if
they're trying to genuinely help people
i got no issue there but talk about the
psychotic cult world we live in in which
ahmed arbory is getting a holiday for
him look
i
maybe i'll be one of the few people
willing to uh
call out as it should be called out
but
uh during the ahmed aubrey trial so we
just had those the the three individuals
in question mcmichaels and that other
guy they're convicted on federal hate
crime charges
you've got uh you've got a story that is
very clearly nuanced and contentious and
it is not as clear-cut as the
establishment and mainstream media tried
to say the fact is the narrative of a
guy jogging down the street was a total
fabrication a lie to manipulate people
that brings us to a point where now
we're having a holiday for this guy look
i'm sad the guy lost his life and all
that stuff but it's not so simple we can
say the mcmichaels were wrong the guy
who filmed all of it happening i don't
know why he's going to prison but sure
fine whatever
the fact is
this is the level of insanity in this
country i gotta say so the guy with the
camera went to jail i think because he
had a car and he was behind him and they
thought it was he was part of like
pinching the guy in like like blocking
the guy in okay if that guy's going to
jail for using his car as a weapon think
about these truckers
if they go around dc and pin the
president in while he's trying to give a
speech oh come on come on yeah come on
come on but look what they did to a
modern arboretum no it's it's sort of
the situation it totally is isn't it
yeah the guy with the camera's in jail
because he had a car there yeah that
that's completely five feet away from it
and what was the reason he went to jail
because they said that he was part of it
we're having a conversation about ahmed
arbour he's a little off topic there's
nothing to do with trucks well the
camera guy shouldn't have gotten went to
jail i don't think that guy shouldn't go
to jail he was there but they said that
he was pinning ahmed arbory in basically
he was he was like blocking him from
running and when he had no way
coordinated with the other man but it
didn't matter because we live in a
psychotic cult reality where lunatics
the the the inmates are running the
asylum
yeah i mean i don't know how he got this
day faster than george floyd
yeah what's up is there a george floyd
day or no i don't know yeah i don't even
know if there's even george floyd yeah
but the fact that uh aubry got it
quicker than him uh i think look at this
the george the georgia general assembly
passed a resolution on february 2nd to
permanently declare february 23rd to be
ahmed arbory day
you know
i don't know
look man
i'm all about justice
i i don't like uh racists if a group of
guys are chasing down a dude who's
jogging because he's black i want to see
justice if they if they kill him lock
those people up you go to prison for
that but that's not what happened the
media lied about everything and you know
what's funny is conservatives many of
them not all of them but a lot of them
are complicit in pushing this narrative
and it's it's fascinating
i i we've heard it before but i
genuinely think
a lot of republicans
they they they try and act like they
oppose the democrats but they're so
they're so worried about not being uh
they're so worried about
what the left thinks of them stepping
out yeah yeah so i mean what we see fox
news we saw even you know tulsi gabbard
i guess she's a progressive but all
these these people are coming out being
like see
what happened here in georgia was right
and i'm like what how are you going to
come out and be like what happened to
kyle rittenhouse was wrong and the media
lied and now believe the media on this
story when it was just patently false
what happened the story is i'll simplify
it for you a string of robberies in a
neighborhood
gun gets stolen police go door-to-door
saying this is the guy with an image of
him he's seen on security camera footage
entering someone's house the prosecutor
said that makes him a felony burglary
suspect under georgia law you can
citizens arrest someone without probable
cause
with only probable cause without
actually witnessing it if they're
committing a felony
based on the judge's jury instruction he
said i don't know you figured out and so
the jury decided to go the other way and
say they needed to be witnesses that's
the nuance here as for why these guys
got convicted were the jury instructions
correct but the story about a guy
jogging down the street complete lie
complete lie and now the georgia general
assembly is giving this dude a a a a
statewide holiday
didn't think whatever man didn't the guy
wearing work boots
yeah something like that wearing work
boots they said he was jogging i mean
come on you don't got you know what it
is
literally abc says he was killed while
jogging in this same arc there is
several witnesses that that came out and
spoke on record that they suspect that
it was it was a much because they've
already kind of seen some of the
previous behavior
leading up to that moment that it was
what that they believed that it was um
aubry um doing some of the
trespassing according to some of the
neighbors like yeah so i made this
mistake and we had a lawyer on uh we had
i think it was andrew branca as well as
another lawyer i can't remember who do
we have on with brenda with someone else
anyway
was it cash right right right and he was
yes and he was a prosecutor so um
i said trespassing and they said he
wasn't a trespassing suspect when you
when you enter someone so i'll tell you
guys what we're dealing with we had a
guy
drive past two no trespassing signs up a
thousand foot driveway and then enter
our house that is i think it's what is
it fourth degree burglary
that's it
when you when you break a barrier when
you cross a barrier it's burglary at
least in maryland so when they're saying
this guy was trespassing no no no no no
trespassing is if he stepped on the
grass and a sign said no trespassing
then they can be like you knew the sign
there you should have done it by
entering the building it was now felony
burglary
so look i don't think the guy should be
dead
don't think we should have a holiday for
him either i mean this is crazy they're
encouraging communities to quote run
with mod by running 2.23 miles annually
on this day this is from the article
literally if the guy is actually running
from a from a burglary and they want to
make a day
encourage people to do like a a run with
the guy who was running from a burglary
he just committed like how how upside
down is this
reality that they've got people confused
like this i mean i don't get it i mean
if you want to have a obvious like a
holiday for like a malcolm x then of
course
uh but this is they're putting up some
statues of george let me tell you guys
something this is a story that blows my
mind thank you
what i you're probably going to say
something that's going to blow my mind
i love it
thank you
there was a building
with a mural of george floyd wearing a
crown oh yes that's like who was it and
a storm
there was there was there was it was
partly cloudy
and a single lightning strike hit only
the mural on the side of the building
where george floyd's face was that blew
up blew off only the outer portion of
the wall the inner wall remained intact
the roof was undamaged witnesses saw the
lightning strike it was reported by
meteorologists how the does that happen
metallic paint is all i got but only the
george floyd yes i don't know
the whole building was was it was a
mural like if they just painted his face
with some sort of metallic paint they
just blasted off all the metal or i
don't know man but the roof wasn't
damaged
and the lightning typically strikes
chimneys i don't want to glorify people
because they got killed i want to
glorify them because of what they did in
their life and if they happen to have
been killed unjustly that's a big part
of it right but
rando people that got off is not like we
celebrate okay thank you you pointed out
you celebrate malcolm x for what he did
in his life not for getting shot it's
what he did in his life that matters but
but look man
they tear down statues of hans christian
hag they tear down statues of a great
civil rights leaders
teddy roosevelt in new york city they
they took that one of my heroes but
frederick douglass
dude it's amazing he is
one of the one of the most epic
americans in the history of this country
he challenged americans during this this
is the pre-civil war era he said
he you are you going to live up to the
words you wrote in your own constitution
and that's like smackdown you know like
do you really believe i i i can't stand
hypocrisy if you're going to come out
and say all men are created equal we
believe in civil rights and liberty he's
going back okay i challenge you to
uphold that it's brilliant and they tear
they tore his statue down up in
rochester now they want to put up
holidays for george floyd statues and
murals holiday for ahmed aubry and the
georgia general assembly votes the sin
i don't know if you've seen that um that
one story tim it was actually uh the
daily signal um one of our good friends
mary margaret broke the story there was
a catholic church that had um they had
like a mural of george floyd but as a
saint
and that
was like i was like wait wait what what
are we doing now it's called
five drugs in his system according to
yeah yeah and they had they had george
floyd
the dude should not have lost driving
his family around hi
like come on the guy was behind the
wheel of a car high as hell let's
celebrate all this all this movement to
like name a day after ahmad are
putting sane before george floyd this
just takes whatever you think of the
case cases in this case just takes the
nuance out of the discussion like five
years from now 10 years from now when
you look at a statue of george floyd or
realize that oh today is ahmad arbury
day then you probably by default start
thinking that they probably must have
done something
like like good in their life right
or maybe you know they didn't and you're
like i want to be a saint how can i
because i want to be like that guy so
what it does it just whitewashes the
whole incident or just again like
removes any sort of like gray point gray
area from the discussion like these were
good people who were killed and just
mostly that's that's it let's play a
game
trayvon martin story initially reported
boy lies in fact i can't remember which
media outlet it was they actually edited
the 9-1-1 call from george zimmerman to
make it seem like he was racist you
remember that yeah
they asked him that george edmond says
is a suspicious looking guy and they ask
him what race is he and he goes i think
he's black they cut that part out so
it's just george zimmerman saying a
suspicious looking guy i think he's
black like that was the sole reason they
they play these games they claim
zimmerman's a white dude he's he's
latino
then you've got let's see michael brown
hands up don't shoot not true
right what else do we have we have uh
with obviously ahmed arbor he was just
jogging not true george floyd not true
police footage gets released brian
taylor brennan taylor not true
none of it is true these people are evil
they are liars they are trying to
manipulate you to to take power they do
these things because it is part of their
psychotic culture revolution look we can
look at it like a zombie horde an
aimless horde of people who are doing
random things for no reason that may be
the case but if that is the case then
there is a chaotic malignancy growing in
this country that is gutting it and
destroying it yeah people we have
traditions for heroes like frederick
douglass and harriet tubman who did
amazing things that we are all proud of
and brag about yo we had people going
out like like harriet tubman was like
apparently like a badass she had a gun
and she was like super like well trained
with how to shoot and everything like
that leading people to freedom and we're
like that's what we care about we care
about freedom
frederick douglass as i already
explained these are the statues i i
think hans christian hag was my
understanding he's not even american he
would he want he fought for the north
because slavery was was a moral evil
they he died when he was 30. they tore
his statue down
it's not it has nothing to do with
racism has everything to do with erasing
and destroying our heroes our champions
our traditions
racism
enough this stuff just just man it makes
me i think if they had been honest about
george floyd having all those drugs in
his system and behind the car wheel of a
car with his family in the car um it
would be a different it would still be
equally as tragic and worth talking
about and but it would be a different
conversation we'd be talking about drug
addiction and how that is a big problem
fentanyl addiction yeah oh we got it we
got to give a honorable mention to jesse
smallett oh boy oh one of the biggest
parts that's the biggest congratulations
shakti hasn't gotten like a netflix
series can we i'm surprised cnn hasn't
given him like a role how come how come
no one's done it how come no one's made
a jesse smallett story have they done
like like
assuming the story is real
and then dramatizing the incident in
question and make like making a you know
you know they're doing the fresh prince
of bel air drama oh i heard that's so
ridiculous but the smaller thing was
like embarrassing on multiple levels to
like even for them to like sugarcoat it
i know i just think you know can we fund
this
can we do like like a satire outfit yeah
no no no totally legit dramatization of
his story
like as if it actually happened by
framing like him getting out of the
subway and the guys pulling up you might
need to change the names yeah and then i
think you'd be okay juicy jade juicy
smoothies
call them this guy dog dogs yeah
and and i guess we i guess it would be
better if we did it as a parody because
then like he's he's in chicago at 3am
it's 20 degrees out and then like two
fat deliverance kind of guys are like
look at this pretty barn
walk up and then it's like he's like oh
no it's trump supporters
and they're like go trump and then they
try to attack him or whatever i wouldn't
believe the morphy we just said like
kanye attacked him at two in the morning
in chicago i'm like that's more
believable
khan is doing out of pocket [ __ ] all the
time yeah but but but it is i mean at
least kanye's like from he's from the
east yeah
he has a reason to be there he's also
bipolar so you don't know he probably
walks the streets in the middle of the
night
yo man at a certain point i'm just like
do these people really believe this
stuff do you see that that that canadian
mp who said that honk honk is an
abbreviation for oh like a high healer i
don't even want to say god yes that's
what she said and i just i saw that and
i'm like dude no sane person believes
that's true and anybody who claims to is
lying to you and also that that's like
offensive to jewish people too it's like
oh my god
yeah what if it was a jewish drunk
driver yeah
so i feel like that's also offensive to
the jewish community big problem with
demonizing language
i would love to not do that do you think
we can make all the words okay again no
come on you know we're never going back
really do you think the humanity is is
that lost that our language has been
that distorted forever that ship is dude
look at what they're doing to the
spanish language but think about it even
in this conversation we can't say
certain words and i guess i'm already
brainwashed to think that words mean
certain things and they don't really
have to
what like just because i was told that
english means what it means doesn't mean
that it has to mean that
sure but words are basically
um
they're they're tools to describe things
so if we all agree racism means
something it's so that we can convey
ideas to each other the left plays
semantic games on purpose to confuse you
so you don't know how to communicate
properly it's kind of like this you're
fighting someone right
if you are uh the honorable samurai then
you approach honorably from actually no
no let's do this the american revolution
you are the british regular approaching
the battlefield with honor and the
americans are hiding in the brush and
they jump out and just ambush you
that's what the left is doing they're
doing gorilla tactics and politics they
are trying to make sure you are confused
and tripped up and don't know how to and
it's right it seems almost random like
one day a new word will have some other
connotation or be associated or my
favorite is women
yeah you remember this
they changed women with an e to an x and
they said it was inclusive i don't even
say that out loud what did you say
so like so no it's whim whim w-o-m
accent so wimmix in oh wow
confusing as hell so it's you could say
woman or you can say wimmix
they also said you could say womenks
which makes no sense because
it would be
so funny
women could you imagine being a guy at a
bar and you just walk up to a girl like
you're the finest woman nixon i've seen
so check it out
imagine imagine you're you're you're
fighting someone right
here's what here's what we're doing in
this political battle we're approaching
right up front we're walking right up to
them and saying here's my argument and
then all of a sudden some guy jumps out
from behind us with a bow loss and
throws it and tangles up our feet and we
fall down and they run away laughing
they're they're playing these games
remember when um the brett weinstein
thing happened up in uh it was it was
seattle or evergreen college
yeah just outside of seattle i think it
was right and when the when the
administrators were trying to talk
one of the students goes don't wave your
hands at us it's racist so he stops and
then they all start laughing at him
they're not serious people they're
playing a a a power game and so they'll
say
oh uh latinx
latinx or whatever like no no like was
it three percent of spanish people
identify with using those terms
those words what does that even mean no
i mean that's like the funniest thing to
me because it's like you know obviously
i'm latino but just being
you know just i couldn't even imagine
some like white liberal going up to my
dad and being like you're a latinx and
my dad's like
uh you speak spanish yeah can you can
you speak spanish putting an x at the
end of when any any any gendered word
like if it's going to have an o or an a
it's got to be x
i don't know i don't even think you
could even even do that but it would it
would be the most insane thing ever to
try and speak i mean it's just the
latinx thing is like probably the most
funniest thing to me because it's like
you have these white liberal kids who
like go to college at these universities
telling working-class latinos what they
should be called and the things that
these latinos are like you know you're
like hey you're a latinx or like um look
man i just gotta get back to work i
gotta pay bills i don't i'm not even i'm
not even in this discussion like no they
just go okay
what are you talking about what is it
what is latinx
so it's a i mean i would i guess it's a
term made by
uh by white liberals white germanic
language speaking liberals so it's like
a version of taking the non-binary out
of it uh so you can't say like latino
latinos
you know spanish language is very
engendered so like for instance like you
know if you say like
it says
that's my son this is me ha that's my
daughter so everything is like that
everything is gendered so it's so weird
that i don't know why they wanted it you
know why not why not make the asian
agents say asian acts or something i
don't know why hey you know what and i
want to say this too i want to say i
think um
i think that uh spanish is sexist
against men you know why so let me ask
you let me ask you a question all right
what is what does nina's mean
it's girls like but like little girls
like children yeah okay what does ninos
mean
like little boys boys or
ninos yeah oh i see where you're going
what else could it mean it could also be
kids so almost to be like hey these are
the those nino so you could be like oh
these are kids so so let me let me ask
you all girls if there was a group of 10
boys and 10 girls all playing how would
you describe that ninos
ninos so that so hold on a minute you
mean to tell me that in spanish language
girls get their own special words and
can use the masculine as well
well that sounds like they get special
privileges
special descriptors the males don't get
i'm kidding by the way but you see that
that's the game you can play though is
there some value to removing gender from
the language
well
mussolini
was like the national river of italy was
uh feminine and he was like no it is we
are strong masculine country and you
change it to a masculine word and then
they change the words nick says is that
necessary that kind of that
psychological power
in arabic they actually change the
language when they talk to a girl they
use different words for women i don't
know that yeah me me gotex focus
like what are you gonna do to get rid of
the gendered language like just change
the word
meet me got you could use the same word
like you don't have to no no we have
different words for man and woman yeah
who cares that latin roman romance
languages are well like you said it it
says if there's boy and a girl playing
together you'd refer to them as with the
male word it's kind of like why why do
you have it there to begin with then
what are you going to say nick says
children like just
but that's that's you see like this is
the problem with the progressives
telling spanish speakers the words they
have to use because they're politically
incorrect where does it come from it
comes from latin right the the gender
stuff from the roman empire so so uh
like even french romantic and portuguese
they have gendered language as well yeah
it's all comes from latin and that was a
highly patriarchal society i don't know
maybe there's something to it
maybe maybe the progressives are right
and spanish people should just you know
speak the way they're told maybe the
romans built the catholic church and uh
patriarchal language
how is this not the epitome of of white
supremacy that
white wealthy liberals are telling
working-class spanish people that their
language is wrong yeah it feels pretty
uh white knighty that's why i'm glad the
polling shows it only has like two to
three percent support so
but it's not working and it's a huge
turn off as a as a native speaker of
spanish you don't think there's any you
have you ever thought like that's weird
or anything
i mean to me it's completely normal i
think i mean like i said i mean i've
been raised like that it's a completely
normal thing
um
yeah i mean that's
to me that like i said the the latinx i
mean all it does is actually just hurt
the left side because it just turns off
those voters and the polling you know
shows that and i think a lot of people
forget
that a lot of these immigrant families
whether they're coming from latin
america or from china or india they're
even more conservative than your
american conservative so when you push
this type of language it's a huge turn
off and then all of a sudden those same
parents are like wait a minute it's a
little weird and then they put their
kids in public school then now they see
that their kids are being taught
you know transgenderism and kind of
sexuality education it's a it's a huge
turn off and that one thing that means
suddenly kind of investigated a little
bit um last year was
all that all that you know sexual
education or latinx and stuff like that
that actually led to the republican win
in virginia uh for glen younkin and that
parent that parent uprising i think if
you watch mainstream media you would
have thought like oh man all those
parents in loudoun county are white
supremacist parents the majority of them
are like salvadorian and indian parents
who are like we don't want this it looks
like jersey up there well you guys do
you guys remember i think it was in
birmingham in the uk
it a bunch of devout muslims came out to
protest the schools because the schools
were doing lgbtq curriculum and that
created a really weird conflict because
then all of a sudden you had these lgbt
activists coming out walking up to niqab
wearing women being like we're doing
this for you
and they're like we hate you yeah stop
this and it's just like
i don't know i've been to birmingham and
it's the funny thing like when you walk
the streets there are like particular
areas where you can tell that
bangladeshi people are like uh muslim
people live here and they live their own
lives they don't want to be bothered
they have their own little small mom and
pop shops and they send their kids to
the same public school where the rest of
the birmingham people go and they just
want to be left alone right and up comes
the like in uk public education is
completely completely different than the
states insofar as that thinking of like
lgbt stuff and think thinking about you
know racist like uh race stuff is
so part of their curriculum right from
the get-go
so but these people are not used to that
so when you try to teach a bangladeshi
second generation kid that hey you gotta
use this language hey you can't say that
thing hey there is no boy in gold and he
comes back
and tells his parents it's just like a
whole different environment
like you think that that stuff is
awkward in the states but in uk there is
like
no conservative political ground up
school movement like turning point or
whatever in uk it's like there's no
representation of like the other side of
thinking so the immigration the
immigrant population is just like in a
really like no man's land there
i was thinking um
how
oh this thought has a bit escaped me i
was thinking firstly odd that the
british empire is not pushing back
against this stuff i would like to see
them no it's their policy it isn't their
policy why is it their policy but like
uh that what's happening maybe a lot of
these activists of the people that are
pushing these things are childless
people trying to parent other humans
because like when you're an adult you're
like your kid starts crying i know
you're sad i know you're upset but i'm
doing this for your own good and they
may actually be doing that because
you're taming a wild one you're
basically you can't eat all the sugar i
know it's sad i know it sucks but trust
me so these people are doing it for
other people i know it's not the
language you're used to but trust me
it's for your own good like have some
kids gain some humility stop trying to
control people i was thinking about this
like why don't you just let the kid eat
the tuba cookie dough no no because it's
addictive no no because a kid would barf
all over himself and be like i never
wanted anything but then they keep
eating it they go back to it like a dog
puke
i remember i moved to l.a and i was
hungry and i ate a whole pizza to myself
and i was like that was so good and then
i got sick and i was like i'm never
doing this again oh i made a mistake and
i was an adult when that happened oh i
was i made that mistake as a kid over
and over and over again but but i think
there is there's a point there it's uh
because it's it's what we've said before
the the socialists don't have kids they
have yours correct like uh if you think
about it like from that analogy like you
treat your family as like a commune
right you treat your friend group as a
socialist circle the wider you go the
more right-wing think you go like you
treat the the country as like you want
to get the best out of people so you
want
there's there needs to be like a
capitalist structure but for someone who
doesn't have a kid or family or friends
for that matter they want to enforce
their control over the next immediate
group of people that they see and in
this case that's
the rest of the citizen of the country
yeah it's probably naturally um
satisfying to have a little bit of
communism a little bit of socialism
correct yeah like because you have a
right side of your brain on the left
side of your brain you need that balance
just to be a functioning human being and
you use the
left way of thinking for the people who
you actually care about or you have
something to share with like the people
from your same religious circle
or your family or your friends or your
family but the people who you do not
know like strangers you just want the
best out of each other so you think of
them like hey let's be symbolic and you
get the best out of me and i get the
best out of you and there's money
involved so they're
i don't know so there comes like a
capitalist way of thinking
but if you don't have any kids family or
like a religious circle you don't have
anyone to use that left way of thinking
on so you subject that on the rest of
the people have you guys uh seen those
groomer bills they haven't i think it's
florida banned them yeah it was like you
know that the schools wanted to like you
know groom children into
various
ideas or whatever i'm saying that very
specifically i'm i'm i'm using the
phrase groomer on purpose because what
the left is really effective at is
propaganda and what they're saying is
they're calling it don't say gay oh yeah
right you've heard of that wait was i
don't know that what's that so it's just
they're bill saying that schools
shouldn't be having uh
like sex ed for kids as part of the
curriculum should be something special
or not in schools at all should be
something that parents decide and that's
you know my attitude on it is like yeah
i don't know the parents should figure
out if they want to talk to their kids
about this stuff so the left has very um
they're good they're good at the stuff
they call it the don't say gay
so that's clearly not what the bill is
but now all of a sudden that's what the
left is is putting out there and when i
say groomer bill you guys are like huh
what's that it's because the right is
ineffective at correct
they don't they don't have any of that
stuff but you know in these schools
indoctrination is is the key
to what what the left is doing they
don't have kids they have yours which
means if they can get your kids to
believe whatever they believe in 20
years this country will be
whatever their ideology is it's starting
with millennials no all the stuff rising
up and you're right on point and we
actually did uh me signing we produced
our second doc uh documentary was called
indoctrination nation where we looked at
critical race theory in the state of
virginia pacific aladdin county
one of the things that i was shocked
about was that these kids would be like
12 years old unless you know they'll go
to like to the library and their
librarian would tell them hey you should
read this book it's called rick
and rick is you know will be a story
about a girl who then transitioned into
a boy and all this is happening without
the parents knowledge yeah it wasn't
until those still to those kids come
actually home and say hey mom this is
what i learned and then you know the
parents look at it like wait wait what
um so it's a little bit of actually
actually that that you know
indoctrination at a very young age and
it's doing behind the parents back also
in in my home state of california we had
a state assembly member by the name of
scott weiner who actually is introducing
a bill which actually might pass which
is scary a bill that's going to lower
lower the age of vaccination consent
down from the age of 18 down to 12 years
old so could you imagine that if you're
a 12 year old or 13 year old if your mom
says you can't get vaccinated or you
know because obviously she's your parent
but now you could finally go behind your
parents back and still still do this and
you know give more power to this you
know look i i gotta say i blame a lot of
the parents 100 percent
uh i can't tell you how many stories
i've heard where it's like i sent my
daughter to college and now she hates me
and it's like why would you do that
why would you not pay attention to what
you were doing to your children look i
get it man
these these cult weirdos are the problem
but who are i got to say to parents out
there you didn't look into the school
right you didn't go and visit you didn't
ask about the curriculum you didn't
check in on what other people are going
to the school are doing and what they
what they're planning and what's
happened to their lives you're not doing
any research it's crazy to me how many
parents are like i just put my kid in
school and forget about it and then when
their kid comes back and like i can't
believe you're learning this did you not
take any active role in what's happening
to your kids that that version of for
lack of a better word helicopter
parenting is
kind of a privilege if you think about
it right so if there's
a helicopter parenting
like for lack of a better what i said
like well i'm not talking about parents
like micromanaging their kids lives i'm
talking about their parents knowing
about the college they're sending their
kids to instead of being like i signed
the paper by it's like shouldn't you be
like i looked into these schools here's
what i think is best good luck to you
that's fair but what i'm trying to say
is like
that's not possible for you know
a family who's just trying to get by or
like a single like a single mom who's
working a job already and who's just
sending their kid to public school
expecting that everything's going to be
an autopilot like that's not possible
for her and what what where did this
idea come from because it's a new idea
that you could use schools as a daycare
center and you weren't responsible for
what you know oh i thought the schools
the government indoctrinated institution
i thought the government's
institutionalized learning facilities
was going to teach my kid to be
responsible adults who got good jobs did
it ever occur to anybody that when the
government is subsidizing an
institutionalized learning facility the
number one uh function of any entity is
to preserve itself so they're going to
indoctrinate your kids to want to
preserve their machine
if you want your kids to to retain your
values
you are responsible and no one else and
if you send your kids to these colleges
you are responsible for them coming back
with shaved heads and like pierced eyes
or something
but like
what would you say to
a mom like that who doesn't have any
other option than to send her kid to a
public school um i think that uh the
challenge today
is how luxurious we all live excuse me
you go back 100 years this wasn't an
issue
you know uh well maybe a little bit more
than a hundred years i would say even
when i was in high school wasn't an
issue i mean i wasn't get getting taught
the stuff that these kids i mean i was
like basic stuff you were still in an
institutionalized learning facility
absolutely your teachers had liberal
lefty values even going back 20 or 30
years conservative parents put their
kids in schools and the kids came out
liberal it's just that liberal has gone
further and further left as a recent
history so and the internet has really
accelerated this but there was a period
where parents didn't have refrigerators
didn't have cell phones didn't have the
internet didn't have cars and life
sucked
but
as much as it did relative to today
they would take responsibility for their
kids their kids would work with them the
problem now is
when someone says i have to have a job
well it's because you want to maintain
modern living standards which i totally
get and respect who wouldn't why would
who wants to go live in a cave and try
and forage for berries not to mention
it's really hard because property is
basically owned by everybody but there
is the big challenge the system is
ossifying around you to such a degree
you will have no choice but to send your
kids to institutionalized learning
facilities where they will be taught to
hate you hate everything about you and
your family and your history your
country and your culture and if you
don't like it too bad because your job
is more important living in a house with
air conditioning and a refrigerator
absolutely is more important and i mean
that you're gonna starve to death you're
gonna have no food you're gonna have
dirty drinking water and live on the
streets no you're gonna have to live in
this system as prescribed and that means
the state will own your kids unless you
can figure something out unless you
stand up and you vote and like we saw in
virginia young can you know comes in or
whatever so i'm not saying it's the end
it's not i'm just saying this is the
system that has been built all around us
and it is a terrifying one because how
do you escape it when you are trapped in
it you can't just go uh uh you know to
the to the woods as much as i'm i
jokingly say like get out there and go
to the forest i mean like you literally
can't just live off the land anymore
it's owned by everybody there's rules
there's laws and regulations if you are
if you are well off enough and you save
up enough money you can buy land in the
middle of nowhere it's not impossible
you can buy a house out in west virginia
for 100k you get a loan you put down a
thousand bucks if you get a good loan
there you go move out there you'll work
a lot more life won't be as easy but at
least you'll know your kids will retain
your values and won't come back with
their heads shaved believing insane
things i was looking at the history of
public education modern education the
american system uh comes from a guy
named john dewey he was one of the
founders of what's called the
progressive education movement and he
believed that schools this is from
wikipedia uh that we're not only a place
for students to gain content knowledge
but also a place for them to learn how
to live
so to this day the schools are still
teaching people kids how to think and i
agree teaching kids how to learn is
important but when you're teaching them
how to think as in like how how to be
racist
i think the the aberration has grown
bigger than the product at this point
you know i mean i think you know maybe
i'm wrong but at the end of the day
all this still goes down to the parents
so you know even if you know at the end
of the day with the world that we're
living in here in america you're gonna
send out your kids as you know whether
it's woke is left or stuff at school
work it's it's gonna be all around them
so it's up to the family to kind of
build this those structure and values
before you kind of head out to the real
world that's just my opinion i think you
know what my parents did with me i think
helped me out so when i went to the real
world saw some of this stuff i'm like oh
no f that's like when i went out to the
world world one thing that was getting
taught a lot when i was in community
college was the white privilege thing so
you know i would have white professors
or white um other students tell me how
i'm oppressed and i'm like no i'm not
like my dad's an immigrant who escaped
the civil war you know he just taught me
that i have to work hard and that's how
i get ahead i'm not you know we're not
we're not not ahead because we're not
white or anything so i think it's at the
end of the day no matter with all the
propaganda around us and everything it
still just comes down to mom and dad and
the values that you're getting taught in
your house yeah i can't imagine that the
school's job is to teach people how to
how to learn how to live
come on john dewey says the school is
the place for them to learn how to live
that's the parent's job is to teach them
to be honest i never heard the word
white privilege so like i was like 19
years old 20 years old um just because
like it's just my house i was never
taught that you know my mom and dad were
like hey you have to grind you have to
work my dad the mindset he taught me was
first one in the office last one out so
when i was raised like that i just never
heard the word right right i didn't even
know it was a thing until i was like 19
years old in community college and kids
were like hey hori you're in community
college because of white privilege i was
like no i'm not i just you know i just
messed around in high school and that's
why that's why i'm here and i deserve it
i see value to organized education
because i imagine before john dewey was
around that it was just madness like one
schoolhouse would be teaching this the
other won't be teaching this they'd say
the word means this thing they say the
word means that so they developed a
centralized authority that basically
tells us like this is the official
information but now you see how horrible
that can become when they feed you crap
um another thing which like the
conservatives uh left the ball was
this whole concept of they will get
reality checked once they graduate and
face the real world oh yeah because that
never happened for most of these kids i
was wrong about that for sure i was
saying that and what happens is they get
out and they all stand around looking at
each other going the world isn't the way
it's supposed to be so we're going to
force it and the way we're going to do
it is by taking over the hr departments
of corporate america
and that's what gets overlooked so much
like people try to find cause and effect
that's the cause right there
well uh the laws
look um
you've got
the civil rights law which we like but
they take it to the extreme they say uh
you know one of the arguments put
forward by the left is about
separate but equal when it comes to race
and then they say all of those arguments
pertain to gender as well
why why have so if the argument was that
you know different races were different
therefore they get equal access to a
bathroom but there's different bathrooms
based on race why the same for gender
if the genders are legal are equal under
the law how can you say separate but
equal
it's an argument actually being made by
the left over the gender issue and based
on
the the interpretation of the law
there's they have a legal argument so
there has to be a reinterpretation or it
has to be a judicial review or something
but so long as these laws exist they
will exploit them in ways they were
never intended they will change language
to
retroactively change the laws without
any real democratic process
they they're look
these these cult members are good at
what they do in terms of minutes they're
really good like if you think about it
right now it is almost synonymous
to a layman like there's no difference
between equity and equality right
people just throw thro throw around the
world
diversity and equity
like it means nothing like it used to be
when i was in school it was diversity
and equality and we were like i knew
what those words meant and i know what
equality and equity is and what the
difference is yeah equity is communism
yeah equity is the quality of outcome
and equality is equal of opportunity
it's as simple as that but right now to
layman there is no difference right
because the the
the left has been so so so
good at
messaging i think equity i think of
finance
it's uh equities ownership of assets
we're gonna go to super chats if you
haven't already smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends head over to
timcast.com we're gonna have a members
only show around 11 or so p.m we're
gonna be talking uh a bit about how the
metaverse is grooming kids no joke uh
it's it's a very serious discussion that
i i think is a little too spicy for
youtube and we try to be family friendly
so head over to timcast.com we'll have
that conversation up again around 11 or
so p.m and as a member you're supporting
all of our journalists smash that like
button as i said let's read some of
these super chats
all right let's see christopher knowles
says
jbp that's jordan peterson said a while
ago that most government officials in
canada make decisions strictly based on
polls 10 percent poll swing towards
conservative and now they're
backpedaling think there are any
similarities in biden harris's regime
yes
how how quickly did the polls come out
saying people were pissed off and all of
a sudden they start changing and pulling
back on mandates and stuff like that
yeah the mandates start dropping the
masking kids start dropping
uh yeah a lot a lot of similarities dc
chains like that like literally like dc
used to be like all sad and gloomy with
the vaccine mandates in the mass
mandates the vaccine minded and dc
dropped like yeah they say like the
mandate dropped in like 130 days
legitimately here's one um
eriftas of stett says i can't wait for
tim to sell the naming rights to ian's
room in the new compound i'd name it the
gorilla room all right ian your room is
now
sold
for 50 bucks
i'll just do it for fun well no he's
super chatted 50 bucks okay so ian's
room is now officially called the
gorilla room so happy i was gonna call
it that anyway just we need to figure
out who made this awesome sign this sign
right here yeah who's who made this we
got we it was sent to us who who sent
these to us i love these pretty close we
need to get one that says the gorilla
room so we can put it above against
doors gorilla at the gorilla room the
gorilla gorilla room someone already
made the the twitter gorillaroom.com
gorilla room just pictures of ian
gorgeous all right here's a good one
this is omg puppy says cernovich is
warning people not to fall for democrat
honey traps like the u.s trucker convoy
do voter registration stay away from
dubious protests yeah that's a good
point cerno and um jack vasobic have
both kind of echoed that sentiment it's
a good point
you want to be effective voter
registration like scott pressler's been
doing that oh man scott's killing i
don't know anyone who's doing it at that
level i mean he's gonna single-handedly
win republicans elections yeah by
registering people to vote i don't know
why the gop doesn't do anything with
scott because they're the party of no
ideas the democrats of the party have
bad ideas that's the guy yeah yeah i
don't know how the gop doesn't just
contact and be like hey
show us what you're doing we'll help you
whatever resources but they just decide
not to reach out to this guy and he's
killing it on he's everywhere i mean you
just check his twitter he'll be like i'm
in pennsylvania and i'm touring these
five cities i'm in texas i'm here i'm
here um but i'm 50 50 with cernerovich
on that because it's like i feel like
you still need the non-violent protest
and you need to show that workers are
uprising but i do get it that it could
be possibly infiltrated who knows man
it's a tough call all right we got lord
blueberry the first he says tim my wife
was your brunch server the other day you
hooked it up and she wanted me to send
you a huge thank you this is correct we
went out to a very fine establishment
for brunch with the crew and as we were
leaving our server just she said you
know she's like i wanna let you know
that you know my husband's a huge fan of
your show and i was like oh man thanks
so much i really appreciate it we gave a
we give a nice tip that's nice hook it
up um i always i always tip uh really
really well because i'm i'm a communist
well what we should do is
tip the whole staff because if as a
waiter when a really rich person would
come in all the ways would be like we'd
be like piranhas wanting that one person
and whoever got to wait on them would
get a big tip and everyone else would be
really angry at the server and it would
create intense tenseness at the
restaurant there so and the kitchen crew
needs some of that cash too they deserve
it i i once tricked luke it was really
funny
i was like we were at a restaurant and
luke was like you know we had two
separate bills because luke was covering
him and and some of his friends and i
was covering the crew and then he was
like it was one we had one service like
how much are you gonna tip and then i
was like i'm gonna tip big and he was
like well i'll i'll tip you know half of
whatever you do and i was like all right
so i did this massive tip and then luke
was like
and they had to put a bunch of money but
now when we go to these restaurants the
servers like run out they're like that's
the crew i want to help
you you know what i said man when i was
a kid
i said my goal is to get to the point
where i can tip a waitress a ton of
money you know like you there's somebody
who's working an honest day's work you
know maybe they're having a bad day or
something and you're like i'm gonna make
your day one of the best days ever dude
it's like you could give them five days
of work and one tip it like what a
ability for them to get a buffer to do
something they love with their life or
five days i always
i always tip
mad crazy at restaurants yeah me too
yeah over christmas holiday i was just
online tips and i try to leave before
they see the tip yeah
i don't want to be yeah i try to tip
good though where i i will where i was
tipping greatly was uh during the
log downs and i had to go to these uh
barbers that were basically giving these
black market haircuts so anytime i was
getting a black market haircut i i
tipped the guy like five times we got it
we got it we got luke in the chat luke
luke says i still did it that's right
and then luke was like
we got to start tipping
somehow tip the whole staff but i'm
afraid that if you give the tip to like
the manager they're going to pocket it
so you've got to make sure everyone sees
their all right you have to tip the
whole step next time person to person to
person to person just pissing me off and
they're like chef can't take tips and
you're like you know what get out of my
face dude you can't i was at i was at a
local grocery store
during uh i think it was thanksgiving
and there were people there working and
we were picking up a bunch of snack i
think it was thanksgiving and i was like
look at all these people working they're
probably getting paid very little i was
like i'm gonna give them all a hundred
bucks like there's like four or five
people who had helped me out i'm like so
i walked up and i was like can i give
you guys a tip and they're like no and
and i i i i said i was like okay and
there's a guy bagging and he was like he
they can't tip us and they were like no
and if you take it we'll make you give
it back
and then i was like all right man i just
wanted to give you guys
you can give them a gift though
technically legally you're allowed to
give gifts
uh i believe you can write that this is
officially a gift and not a tip and i've
seen it someone tweeted out a picture of
it and it went viral i was thinking like
i was like i wish i could just tell that
you know that 16 year old kid who was
bagging groceries and they said they
wouldn't let it do it i was like i wish
i could just offer my you want you want
to you want to mop the floors here we'll
pay you twice as much as they're paying
you because screw that that's bs right
if i if i'm a customer and i come in and
i appreciate you guys working on the
holidays and i want to pay you extra i
should be able to do it they wouldn't
let me do it
we should read some more more uh super
chats
we got isaac lux he says i haven't heard
you mention
transnistria a disputed area in eastern
moldova housing russian troops on the
southeast border with ukraine look up
simon whistler's video on geographics
for more information that's interesting
i didn't know about that
all right
ardwick says don't think that the
truckers won trudeau declares emergency
parliament delays vote until trudeau
clears protesters parliament votes to
back the emergency trudeau cancels
emergency precedent set
perhaps but i think their polling is
going to be hurt and i think a lot of
people it's it's like confidence is
everything if one day everyone woke up
and said trudeau needs to be out he'd be
out
so if they shatter confidence by doing
this stuff it's a dramatic shift and
they know it absolutely and i like i
said i do think it's a big deal that you
actually had a president like i said
president of assault and naive kill who
who stepped up and spoke out against
what trudeau was doing and i think
that's gonna uh be interesting as as
those uh diplomatic informations further
further but at least salvador thing's
pretty interesting you know it is and as
like i said it's it's fascinating to
actually have a president come out and
speak out against what trudeau
government did and i think it's gonna be
really interesting how we see that
foreign policy play between those two
countries as we go
all right rd says ian's salary based on
the ones and twenty twenties he rolls
i would never take that gamble
i just live life baby
one day it's like his paycheck is
massive well he even rolling 20s man it
was worth it it was worth it yeah it's
not worth it sam says shout out to viva
fry timmy should have him on uh viva is
always welcome we're big fans and uh
it's just difficult with the borders and
stuff but uh anytime viva can come down
we will have him on he was a great guy i
just met him at the uh james o'keefe
release party for his for his book but
he was awesome he was so crucial in the
uh ring house uh coverage i tweeted it
out of all the guests we've ever had on
the only one i fanboyed over was david
freya that's vevo yeah i was just so
excited to meet him he's like my age he
was cool he's cool dude all right hayden
says josh yoder with the people's convoy
talked to ivory hecker today and said
that the convoy will not be going to dc
they have reportedly had feds already
tried to infiltrate the convoy and rile
people up that's interesting though what
i'm getting from my sources i got to
because i got a couple guys on the
ground is that they they're not going to
go into dc proper but uh dc beltway um
and i got i've got my good friends out
there sergio and anthony cabazo out
there following the freedom convoy from
california
chiang saotome says
ian is hearing liberty or death for the
first time in his life from people who
actually mean it and he's so state
brainwashed he can't understand it but
you got also i'm on tv right now so we
have guidelines about what we can and
can't say on tv i fully support
the convoy and the the momentum and the
alteration of fascist governments i want
to break down the federal reserve and
reformulate our economy with something
more
you know at least opportunistically
equitable
adrian contreras says me my roof is
leaking ian the federal reserve
i think i think the point they're making
is that there's a lot of issues that are
pertinent to like working-class people
that aren't solved by these bigger
grandiose issues definitely
all right here's one that's really
really important tattered shield says
tim i have done what you said and got
off the american dollar i have done
nothing but buy magic the gathering
goblin tokens for three days
62 000 goblin tokens i never at any
point instructed anybody to let alone
get uh get off
get off the american dollar let alone
buy goblin tokens for matching the
gathering but i do think hmm
no i'm kidding he will spawn 62 000
goblins in one turn i mean just so you
know tim coins we we we have like we
have commander decks that can generate
that many kikijiki i mean that's
infinite tim
i don't know if they're goblins though
kicker the bird dude beanie coins okay
yeah he's uh the token generator guy
i've actually had like i've had to use
like three 20-sided dies so sign one of
those goblins send them the p.o box
and uh maybe tim will slip one in his
deck
we gotta i saw i saw uh a couple people
playing chess today and i was like y'all
gotta play magic the gathering because
there's more spice to it it's like chess
turn-based strategy game but it's also
like poker not knowing what your
opponent has is cool
yeah like you're trying to guess what
cards they might be using based on the
actions they're taking it's like chess
and poker combined good game and plus
that new neon japanese set came out oh
yeah
it's a new kamigawa
set yeah and it's like digital future
neon something or other card games are
fun
i should i should make some more decks
just don't have time
all right raymond g stanley jr once
again says ian sir as someone who has
done time and someone who has served in
our beloved marine corps i'll gladly get
arrested for the freedom of our people
okay
for the freedom that's very vague though
you know planning is every it's almost
everything right now uh organization and
planning is a big part of them and then
the action comes after the organization
and the planning is done
howard with a great super chat thank you
for the super chat says first they came
for roller 20. it was not me then they
came for roller 15 not me then they came
for 10 not me then they came for roller
one ian then i said i should have honked
yeah
role initiative
wise words
caligula uh what does it say
caligulov says ian in the words of
george carlin white collar blue claw
blue collar it doesn't matter what color
shirt you have on the elites are
screwing all of us
yes or basically uh as george crowley
would say it's a big club and you ain't
in it
that's my favorite quote of all time
brian wisecarver says i emailed spin the
ufo gmail i haven't heard back from you
guys but i'm still recording and
documenting everything while
volunteering with the people's convoy
let me know if you guys have any
questions about it or want any
first-hand information yeah so what i
did with that was forward it on to chris
carr who is our editor-in-chief i think
yeah there you go so he's got that
information now and i can send him
anything more that you send to me and we
are coordinating coverage but we
got to figure it out it's it's not you
know it's not super easy there's a lot
of conflicting information so we're
trying to figure it out
all right what do we got casual gamer
says hi tim i'm a meat rapper with
safeway the company gave us hazard pay
at the beginning of covet stopped six
months later and now giving it to uh
giving it to us as back pay for the past
six weeks five dollars an hour extra
that's cool
yeah yeah
i think they're unionized i like that
yeah workers first all day yeah right on
all right let's grab some super chats
here let's find a good one
doo doo doo
sean hirschbach boak says
bowick tim i love when you have
documentarians on any chance you can
have ami horowitz on the show i would
love to have amihora hor what's on the
show uh have you ever reached out to him
i don't think so we should obviously be
great
he's fine you know
richie richie's over here like i got
your pictures man i'll call him right
now
richie hiding in the back of his digits
this guy
i knew that richie was here because um
the skate park is directly beneath where
i where like my like work my office and
everything is and then all of a sudden i
i hear banging and oh
like someone fell
and i was like yeah rich
like two minutes was like you guys ready
to skate
yeah yeah
oh there's some solid video richie
tearing it up on his twitter right now
yeah oh really yeah richard was killing
it man you should have got here early so
we could have you launch off the uh into
the six foot airbag
you can come by come by the weekend
we've got a couple some smaller ones
coming too so you can launch really high
into smaller airbags it's going to be
fun yeah andy did a front flip today it
was cool amazing yeah
let charles says ian if people don't
want to be annoyed by protests maybe
they shouldn't live downtown of the
country's capital still love you or do i
love hating you
probably both
yeah yeah it's a big
relationship with you there's scratching
an itch you know it feels good but you
don't want to do it too much that's true
there is a point put some water on it
could you imagine ian like you know how
many protests are in dc right
uh no actually no like a yearly i don't
have any ideas 500 i don't know there's
some there are some permanent ones like
if you drive by down downtown uh capitol
hill area outside the washington house
to the white house there are like
six who never move period there's this
guy who has the the planet side the
earth in his sign and he just holds that
all day all right now i was gonna tell
you too simon there's like you know
there could be random days in dc where
like you're driving to work and you'll
be stopped by like six climate
protesters
you know so yeah if you if you live in
your nation's capital you are surrounded
by protest non-stop always i wish they
knew that making an internet video
channel is the best form of protest
because you're going to reach magnitudes
more people than standing it outside and
holding a sign
yeah rumble is where it's at so we're
we're talking about you know how we're
going to expand and like what the plans
are and you know until we get pop
culture crisis
cass castle and inverted world like more
sustainable we're not going to be
launching we're not going to start
launching off crazy shows until we get
worked on in these so make sure you
subscribe to pop culture crisis on
youtube follow uh brett dasavik who
hosts the show as well as miracle and
everybody else on the show but um
we're if we do anything else moving
forward it's probably gonna be on rumble
so some some stuff will we'll be on
youtube for sure but if we're like we're
thinking about doing live gaming not
it's gonna be on rumble right yeah
because twitch is too risky
you someone asks you a question you
passively are playing you know i'm
playing for a bit in west right now
horizon for ben west i love this game uh
zero don was fantastic and and you're
you're playing and someone asks you a
question while you're playing and then
also you're banned
screw that yeah just do it on rumble man
rumble's where it's at man you know what
i should probably just stream it because
i play for like an hour every day yeah
and on twitch i mean while gaming people
say out of pocket [ __ ] all the time and
on twitch you might just get you know
yanked for like no good reason yeah they
they they temporarily banned destiny
because he said cal written out defended
himself yeah it was like someone asked
him a question and he said it and then
yeah twitch is nuts say amazon what do
you expect i missed the old days when i
was like 13 14 on the call of duty and i
mean anything to fly there
you would hear all things about your
mama on those on those about your mother
yeah you learned about your mom on those
chests
matthew gill says tim tim's cat shall
now be known as buckex buckets buckets
oh because the o is gendered so buckets
oh right
all right simulated dave says saw some
we are change and free hong kong merch
out at alonto today so encouraging to
see tim kess reaches the hellscape that
is cali follow view found media and ig
tim cass inspires me to make new content
hey man glad to hear it amazing it's
always cool when i see people wearing
the shirts because we have we have a
shirt um at timcast.com called join the
cult yeah but it says join the city
urban liberal types but c-u-l-t is in
red and then it's uh it's kent our
animator's version of the meme where the
two guys are like doing the soy mouth
and pointing behind them
and then it's like the city's being
destroyed by aliens and godzilla and
they're like oh and it says join the
cult i think it's a funny shirt but uh
yeah people have been buying it we never
did like a strong promotion for that
shirt we just put this stuff up that's
fun yeah and people are buying it so
that's really cool appreciate you guys
buying the shirts love it
all right we got this one here from
anno i think ian had too much sugar
today because you are just rolling fives
way too much bro oh really yeah but five
is actually better than people are
saying one it depends on what your
bonuses a one is an automatic failure a
five if you get a plus 19 to your roll
is a 24 so you can get a lot
accomplished with good bonuses high
stance yeah and um i do think it's
really funny that one and 20 basically
mean agree or disagree now it's so
polarized i love that that's like we're
creating this polarized system well no
we're like
people didn't use to say very simply i
agree with what said or disagreed so now
if like someone says something on the
show you'll get 300 ones or 20s we might
have cracked the culture code here i
think how to do instant polling i think
we broke through with the critical 20s
and
failures yeah we did huh yeah yeah we
got some tapping into the amygdala oh
here we go
david troutman says i hear you're having
trouble buying electric guitars i build
them how about i build one for the show
love your work keep up the good fight
tim i'll email you if you're interested
yeah we were i was actually looking at
some um
some uh individuals who who craft
guitars because i was thinking like
maybe we get a like a tim cast
unique signature guitar that we would
you know use for shows or maybe like two
of them
so team caster what tim caster yeah
is the telex is telecaster like
proprietary
i think we can say
call the tim caster i think we could
should i not have set that all out yeah
could do it immediately tim caster
somebody locked that in that's great
everyone's posting 20s now okay so
so uh yeah david email spin the ufo at
gmail.com david troutman
and uh let's get a guitar built let's
make it fancy can we can we get it made
out of like some like ancient wood from
you know an
aluminum
made of like petrified wood petrified
milk cartons from a meteorite put like
an amber gem in the neck or something if
you can i'm just kidding dasher says tim
what do you think about beanie coin
credits to the chat
um
yeah we were talking earlier on a
meeting with the onf the uh our charity
open network foundation talking about
creating crypto and whether or not it
would be better to use one that's
already been created mine's token the
minds token yep or like an array of
tokens that have already been created
because creating one brings in
sec regulations and then it's almost
like it's another business completely
correct
so i think with uh the on foundation you
know if those aren't familiar the goal
is to make unsensible networking
technology so you can have your own
member website like locals or patreon
but it would also network with other
sites
no one would have the ability to ban
anyone else you would have the ability
to ban someone from your site so like if
if if you're on an unfettered network so
let's say you go to ian's website
there will be a portion of it where you
can see other people's networking
through his site like you'll see his
posts on your site people can see your
posts on his site depending on what like
this kind of server the system they're
using so it's basically decentralized
social media tech but ian could be like
on my website i don't want to ever have
tim's content come up and could like
lock you up that's how the fetivers
works
so that's that's our plan there i think
mine's token works because they're
already an established social network
with a crypto that's valuable it's like
what three dollars two to three dollars
yeah fluctuates somewhere one point five
to four i've seen it at four but it's
but
first of all uh you know i know bill
uh the ceo ian you weren't
my brother i mean i love the guy you're
one of the co-founders of mines over a
decade so we we and and i trust them
that's why it's important
but if we can integrate with an existing
network
i think that's what will make this
software work because if we were just to
launch like here's the thing that works
some people might use it if it's to
integrate with a website that already
has like a couple million users i think
you know how many how many millions yeah
several four million a day or something
yeah i don't know then people are going
to start adopting our software it's
beneficial to the mind's ecosystem
because that grows and it creates a
large node with a bunch of smaller nodes
hopefully we can we can we can make some
let that grow so that um
you know facebook we got to build a
cultural hub of decentralized social
media this is something which people are
not talking about enough like content
creation on like the blockchain for
example like the web 3 which people are
like throwing around
like people creating like untethered
content and the entire base of it is
like the blockchain i wonder if we'll go
into this on the after show i know
mentioned child sweatshops it's not even
the metaphors yeah yeah yeah yeah you're
talking about blockchain content which
can never be erased no it's grooming in
the metaverse dude
it's dark so there's there's bonuses to
having your stuff on a blockchain
because it can't be deleted but then the
downside is it can't be deleted so
correct
all right sargon of assyria says would
you have billy corganon yes in a
heartbeat i'm a big fan of the smashing
pumpkin pumpkins i met billy corgan and
it was like a totally amazing experience
because um a friend of mine was friends
with one of his
exes and we went to one of his shows
i'll give you the short version
i walked in and he was signing posters i
got there late and i saw him like oh so
cool like billy corgan man he's red and
then we watched this uh this like uh
music video
movie for his music and then after we
left
you know my friend is like hey i'm gonna
talk to my friend who is billy's ex do
you want to meet him and when i walked
up the first thing that billy says to me
uh he goes hey you're tim pool and i was
like wow
this was a couple years ago dude i was a
little kid growing up listening to
smashing pumpkins and playing those
songs in my cover yesterday or tomorrow
i called it yesterday that's funny it's
the day today
he's a super cool dude and he signed a
poster for me and he was like he's like
yeah i like i like your work and i'm
like dude i said to him i was like you
have an idea how crazy it is like i'm
yeah i think i was like 34 or whatever
at the time or 33. i was like dude
you're billy corgan i grew up listening
to your music and i come up to you and
you're like hey you're tim poole i'm
like it's mind-blowingly awesome dude i
appreciate it siamese dream was so epic
because it was almost like an
orchestrative piece with like with like
high strings and then it's just but
there's like a rock album too it's like
a dirty rock album
he did a really good job at putting that
together whoever i don't know if they
produced it themselves but i love
smashing pockets back when i was in
middle school
yeah yeah i did oh i was a big fan of
nirvana back in oh plus i'm golden days
plus being from chicago that's going in
the song the city by the lake i was like
yeah chicago man like that's us we live
there and this song's so big
but it was cool because the song was
like uh epic orchestral you know tonight
tonight so that for me i was listening
to that and i was like wow
yeah
good stuff not to mention 1979 zero just
so much good music man i love i love uh
avador
i said billy actually was on rogan it's
that's a good interview if you guys
haven't seen that yet check out that one
didn't he say that he saw aliens once
he's he's tapped it tuned in yeah you
know what's the um oh man i forgot it
was a dude from blink 182
that was on rogan he was like oh tom
yeah i'm the long he was all into the
aliens he was saying how the hell the us
congressman invited him into dc
uh he's always something to the stars to
the stars academy yeah yeah has always
been big on ufos they have a song about
on animal of the state old song silly
silly band and fart jokes all the way
but
you know to the stars songs called alien
is called aliens exist
all right we used to play he'd be a good
guest
tom that'd be great yeah that'd be super
cool talk about aliens yeah i mean look
if we could get a friday morning and tom
delonge
oh for sure those are the good things
that'd be amazing it's so fun yeah you
jam with him yeah a great band all right
everybody if you haven't already smash
that like button subscribe to the
channel we're to get ready to start
recording that members only segment
talking about really nightmarish things
grooming in the metaverse and you want
to check this out because it's dark
stuff and we could use your support by
being a member you help keep our
journalists employed you help make this
show possible and we love you so much
for for the support we really do
appreciate it so again smash the like
button you can follow us at tim cast irl
on instagram or wherever else you can
follow me at tim cast basically wherever
do you guys uh want to shout out
anything
yeah um big thing right now guys is
please please check out the hero to zero
documentary that we just released um the
link is also gonna be in the description
so it's hero20doc.com please check out
the documentary share it with anyone you
can just to get the story out regarding
the first responders and everything that
they've been going through help us come
back to cover media also um check out
our very first documentary meaning sonic
produced is the cartelville usa cartel
that one is carteldoc.com into the
illegal marijuana operations involving
drug cartels human smuggling in
california so please check it out my
personal social media on twitter is is
really easy so it's my last name ventura
with the with the word report so into
our report either on instagram it's
jorge ventura tv follow us so like that
you guys get all the updates on all the
news that we're working on um all the
stories that we're we're gonna be
working on so right now we're gonna be
following the freedom convoy the
truckers um then sonic me and sonic
pretty soon go up actually to north
northern california shots the county and
going to be looking at their legal
marijuana operations and their drug
cartel uh involvement
same thing yeah document uh the
documentaries which we make we put like
two months per effort into it so it's
really helpful if you guys check that
out and my personal handle is under core
and s-a-g-n-i-k-b-a-s-u on twitter it's
awesome to see you guys awesome really
great to see you again and thanks for
coming if you guys want to check out a
show that jorge did with us where we
talked about the cartels it was really
powerful from uh i don't know five six
months ago or something like that it's
here on this channel so check that out
i'm ian crossland and check me out ian
crossland.net if you want to get in
touch i'll see you later and i'm also
here in the corner i pushed all the
buttons on the show and i have to say i
got to thank richie for this amazing
beer richie always brings me beer this
beer looks like um sour patch kids and i
thought it was beautiful and it is
delicious so thank you very much
i really appreciate it and you guys can
follow me on twitter at sour patches and
also on mines.com we will see everybody
over at timcast.com around 11 or so p.m
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you